pour le pour le deuxième match
de la journée entre Maximilien alsarin
il y a un tout petit peu de retard
écoutez c'est pas très grave on va on va
attendre de toute façon on est reparti
pour 4h ensemble ça nous amenait jusqu'à
23h journée vraiment extraordinaire des
chèques
j'en ai vraiment des chèques
extraordinaires avec 9h 9h de
compétition lance pitch
c'est bon
c'est vraiment très beau
on attend le début du match on voit
qu'il y a un peu de retard c'est pas
très grave
on n'est plus à ça près j'ai envie de
dire
on est plus à ça près donc on attend il
y a pas grand chose d'autre à faire
enfin match intéressant on va voir ça
peut tourner vite court intéressant
parce qu'on est français mais le match
peut vite tourner court on verra de
toute façon
on y est maintenant que sont
intéressants ou pas de façon il va
falloir le suivre ce match
le précédent de Maxime a pas été très
intéressant celui-là devrait plus l'être
après on verra c'est
on verra si on peut se délecter ou pas
ça va être chaud ça rime on verra ouais
ouais c'est ça dépend de quelques
facteurs ouais normalement ça devrait
être assez facile si c'était ouais
j'aurais très confiant mais là ouais on
peut pas savoir donc
plutôt sans rien que devant n'importe
quel autre match ah bah ça je suis
d'accord avec toi j'ai l'anity pas de
baquet aujourd'hui non Baky il est parti
en Espagne pour jouer son tournoi
quel type de joueurs farine c'est
vraiment un objectif pour lui le speech
c'est un joueur de type Internet
il bloque un peu en réel mais sur
Internet il est très très fort
je vais regarder quel âge il a là je
suis en train de regarder mais on attend
il y a un peu de retard mais c'est parce
que l'autre match c'est terminé il y a
pas longtemps aussi donc
l'arbitrage a commencé un peu plus tard
il est né en 2004 donc il plafonne
toi qui est favoris ici c'était sur
échiquier j'irai MV à la quasi 100%
victoire
là dans ces circonstances là je sais pas
là je peux pas dire ça peut très bien
être quand même Maxime comme comme ça
Rin en fait c'est difficile de savoir
ça peut être l'un ou l'autre
il y a trop de facteurs à l'extérieur
qui peuvent jouer
pour pouvoir donner son favori à ce
match
donc donc je vais pas je vais pas donner
de favoris je vais espérer que Maxime
gagne évidemment mais ouais ça peut ok
il peut se faire juste complètement
écrasé aussi donc on peut pas voilà
c'est pas c'est pas un cas de figure on
peut savoir
trop de choses qui peuvent impacter
avec le maillot évidemment
donc je préfère pas vous faire de
fausses joie en vous disant Maxime ok
sur échiquier c'est sûr que
mais bon ça arrive il a été quand même
numéro 1 mondial on Blitz devant ikaro
sur chiascom donc c'est c'est
extrêmement fort
c'est extrêmement fort après je sais pas
j'ai jamais vu autant performer en réel
mais peut-être qu'il joue moins envie de
s'en réel j'en sais rien moi en tout cas
il semblait être super monstrueux ouais
envie de sur internet il semble être
très fort après on verra enfin
je sais pas comment dire en fait je peux
pas savoir
on serait en belote aussi ouais on peut
pas on peut pas dire
peut-être il a une très belle acuité
touristique aussi on sait pas
espèce de chat ça arrive en nettement
moins fort ouais vu que Maxime est déjà
plus fort à mon avis dans ce format
fearuja
ça devrait aller mais après je sais pas
c'est un genre de fille ou jamais en nul
quoi comparativement à firuja c'est
rouge là qui joue sans points de moins
donc normalement pour Maxime c'est pas
un problème mais
ils ont des problèmes de caméra c'est
pour ça que vous voyez les caméras qui
bougent comme ça
ben non mais hyper fort en ligne ça rime
il était numéro mondial en blitz devant
Carlsen et Nakamura qui est en try hard
donc c'est très impressionnant mais
après je le vois pas plus fort que
Maxime c'est plus fort que moi
mais oui numéro un mondial c'est très
fort évidemment
mais pour moi maxime est trois
catégories au-dessus
on verra
on verra après pour moi maxime est gros
favoris après
je peux me tromper
comme pour tout sportifs la forme du
jour J peut changer bien des choses
alors pour le moment on s'est pas trompé
pour le moment pour moi il y a eu zéro
surprise on s'est speechs on va voir
peut-être aujourd'hui la première on
espère pas
pour le moment tous les tous les matchs
se sont soldés par le VAC le vainqueur
attendu
on va voir si ça continue comme ça on
espère et qui est un peu de changement à
partir des demies avec une victoire de
mvel contre ikaro c'est tout ce qu'on
souhaite
les fêtes de fion contre ça c'était
prévisible ouais avec firou qui regarde
sur
qui navigue sur internet pendant son
match oui c'était assez prévisible quand
même
en tout cas moi j'aurais mis sauf favori
non mais de toute façon les seules
personnes qui peuvent qui peuvent gagner
ce tournoi sont mvl Carlsen ikaro et
wesleo donc c'est normalement ce qu'on
va retrouver en demi-finale sont les
quatre meilleurs les autres matchs sont
un peu là sont un peu des fervaloirs ça
arrive normalement il a aucune chance de
gagner
on va voir mais normalement la finale
sera Magnus contre ricaro en espérant
que que on ait une surprise
car romain était pas déconnant la
dernière fois car on a absolument aucune
chance de gagner cette compétition
c'est impossible qu'il gagne
en fait
aucune chance depuis le début non les
seuls qui ont des chances
favoris Carl scène 2 saut 3 ML4 en gros
quelque chose comme ça surtout à cause
de la table partie tableau de Maxime qui
joue qui tombe dans le truc du carreau
quoi
mais donc en gros on devrait avoir les
quatre favoris en demi-finale
mais c'est aussi comme je le disais la
force de ce de ce format c'est comme
c'est des matchs qui sont extrêmement
longs ça laisse vraiment peu de place
aux surprises et 40 devant Magnus
largement dans ce format là
moi j'aurais hyper intéressé de faire un
speed chass sur eshi réel pour voir si
on a les mêmes les mêmes favoris ou pas
je pense qu'il y aurait quelques
quelques petites différences
genre un Ding pour être très dangereux
par exemple
Ikao serait bien sûr un peu moins favori
le Bullet serait là pas on a déjà joué
il y a tant de souvenir que ça changeait
non non il y a de la DIF
en ligne il y a une différence Maxime
qui change de cas ouais c'est un peu
galère là
il y a de la différence aviation
visualisation de l'échiquier est
différente puis bon là en plus c'est du
online à la maison tout seul
c'est pas tout à fait déjà pareil que du
hybride
pas la même chose en termes de
conditions de jeu de jouer dans un lieu
neutre
versus joué dans sa chambre ça change
quand même quelques petits trucs déjà
et Maxime calmaillot évidemment vous
pouvez trouver un bitstream.shop si vous
le voulez le Yoma allez Maxime
allez on est chaud ça fait ça fait 5
heures qu'on s'ennuie là pour enfin
avoir ce moment que ça parte là il y en
a marre
et oui le Blitz screenshot stunt pour
avoir le même maillot que Maxime
important maillot de requin requinade
d'ailleurs je pense que les maillots de
requins doivent mieux partir avec les je
suis en train de me prendre de la
chanson du Baby Shark à fond avec Sofia
allez on attend que ça parte
quel est ton polo ouais je sais je sais
je sais frérot attendez c'est peut-être
pas participer on a peut-être les gars
qui sont pas partis comme pour les
autres matchs
ouais c'est parti c'est parti on a la
Game qui est pas parti avec le mode
théâtre et tout
or on a rien raté on a raté trois coups
et demi je m'en suis rendu compte en
regardant la cam que ça jouait attendez
il faut bien que je mette le follow
comme il faut
OK
allez c'est pas bien là je me délècte
allez Maxime défonce le
j'ai du Baby Shark à fond
voilà
pour pour notre Maxime
le fou qui revient aussi
et ce qui peut envoyer un petit cavalier
en éclaireur là on a quoi trop ca va
aller prendre un cap si on prend quatre
fous prends H4 vous prend c'est 6 ça
peut aller il fait cavalier si c'est
peut-être bien joué
il veut envoyer du cavalier C4 ouais
c'est bien là ce que fait Maxime
du Baby Shark dans le
dans le chat
on est d'accord que tu es obligé d'avoir
des enfants pour connaître le Baby Shark
le Baby Shark il est il est il est
magnifique quoi
avec Maxime
l'enfant on peut petit frère ouais
il a fait tout à 8
allez lui planter un cavalier c'est quoi
trop là à un moment donné
et lui faire mal
elle va faire Dame des 7
tiens
peut-être ouais pour échanger ça va ça
se passe bien
je vois des trucs dans le chat là je
suis un peu perdu en tout cas la partie
se passe pas mal
nous le pion C6 peut être un peu
sensible il tient la casse C4 NiAl
bon ça va Maxime à l'air assez
tranquille
bon reste ça a l'air de tenir un je vois
pas trop ce qui va pas
voilà je raconte non pas
il va un peu attaquer le pion mais
Maxime baltonien
vous prend des six dames
il va essayer de faire du dames C2
une tour en C8 et tenir ce pion
bon si le pion était en B4 on serait
vraiment bien qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
il veut cavaler c'est quoi le garçon
qu'est-ce que c'est bizarre
mais alors ça j'ai pas la ref parce que
Dame des 7 qui a validé ses sept ça
paraît tellement débile
enfin il est pas moins bien mais
pourquoi tu fais ça en fait
en réalité les Blancs étaient mieux il y
avait le pion c'est 6 qui était faible
si vous vous rappelez du scénario de la
partie bon là on a le scénario le pion
c'est si c'est un peu faible on a envie
d'essayer de le taper
et là il est parti voir dans un avantage
de life
c'est étonnant
alors d'accord il a le pion passé et les
blancs sont pas moins bien mais juste il
passe de d'une position qui semble être
petite avantage tranquille
où on peut travailler à position
chaotique après c'est son style
style un peu bizarre
mais c'est tellement double tranchant
Maxime va faire cavalier
à mon avis
planter un punto vers H4 si il peut et
naviguer
c'est pas le coup de la turbine mais il
veut peut-être cavalier aussi s'il veut
torcer 8 OK et surtout B8
dame B3
qui peut tenir la 8e ça peut peut-être
être dangereux
ouais ça paraît bien tu auras un
et là ça devient dangereux parce qu'il
va réussir à avoir tout à 7
bon alors il va faire cavalier 4 avec
l'idée tour à 7 d'avoir du dameux
et cavalier E4 pour C8 ça doit pas être
grave ouais cavalier 4 jouer évidemment
on n'a pas le temps de faire cavaluer
aussi c'est un peu ça qui est dommage
parce que ton C8 gêne
F3 on va pouvoir au pire naviguer vers
des SIF 5 ça a l'air d'aller
j'aime bien les Noirs la jauge
franchement je la comprends pas bon
évidemment il a un peu de jeu mais ça
c'est les chevaux c'est dangereux
qui fait j'ai trois
je pense qu'il va y avoir un coup de G6
côté Maxime
ou de H5 ici
j'ai 600 j'ai tous les coups de Maxime
en fait c'est trop même réflexe c'est
pour avoir du roi G7 et se libérer la 8e
pas bon signe pas sûr on a un style qui
se ressemble
là c'est que des coups dans la normalité
il va juste la gagner en fait c'était
Nimps ce cavalier C7 l'ordi d'un
avantage blanc mais regardez Sarine qui
suit et oui il suffit pas que de jouer
les coups de l'ordi il faut les
comprendre
ça devrait pas suffire alors là sur
Damon roi G2 tours en B3 tu reprends F7
tour B1 il y a torréfi 3f8 mc8 mad bon
ça j'avais direct évidemment
c'est pas
c'est pas parce que la jauge doit
davantage que c'est fort
cavalier
ça a l'air d'aller
6 ok alors prends un Hachette de
comprendre
c'est un peu la sauce là
et pas ton point achète pour ordi avait
tu reprends H7 mais trop dur pas jouable
et là on a pas d'âmes B6 qui est prend
des quatre c'est quoi le bail sur dame
B6
j'avais raté aussi
cavalu E4 c'est obligé
on est pas bien mais il a plus de temps
d'un F3 dame C8 cavalier 8
d'un F5 c'est la même idée
ah le roi est tellement mal
ça menace d'âme C8 là on a pas le temps
de faire
H5
arrive à la perdre Maxime c'est trop
tu fais de la F3 maintenant B4 allez G5
OK
il y a réellement rien à faire
ah c'est trop
il veut revenir vers 4
mais le pion pousse et on peut rien
faire
allez Maxime
c'est trop
c'est trop ah c'est trop d'avoir perdu
ça
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
c'est tellement bien c'était tellement
fort ce qu'il avait Maxime
ça dégoûte en vrai
ouais ça rend qu'il est qu'il est plus
tenir
non mais il est fort il est fort ça il
n'y a rien à dire
il y a rien à dire
il y a un côté un peu il caresse que
ouais
il y a un côté un peu il caresse
ça va pas ça va pas être simple bon on a
un rock opposé
ok 3 allez il va falloir réussir à
envoyer G4 ou des trois tours géants
trop tôt H6 ouais beaucoup trop tôt tu
vas te faire fermer parfois les cinq tu
as juste perdu
ok Maxime qui va tout échanger et faire
H6 là peut-être
allez faut que Maxime va mettre la
pression
H6
attends C4 pour se débarrasser des pions
doublés
cavalier C2 c'est sûr des quatre
décapnextes aller D4 là pour remettre
les pions sur sur noir là
il faut me rajouter un peu de
pions sur sur case noire là il y a trop
de BLANCO là
il veut mettre le pion F
il y a trop de pions sur Blanco là
il faut que ce soit l'adversaire qui est
les pions sur blanc pour rester avec le
fou
ouais faut qu'il va être quelques
quelques white adversaire là
donc sur Fougères il y avait et puis on
prend G5 il faut prendre 2 G6 échecs qui
est important
mais attention et là ce pion sur white
là qui peut être mal
pour ça qu'il hésite à faire roi prend
OK
c'est compliqué en fait comme position
là il y a pas cavalier aussi
tu auras fuite qui va laisser 5 tours H5
D4
car F4 c'est quand même fort c'est mieux
au blanc là trop de White chez
les noirs
ouais non là il est un peu ouais la
maximise domine le cavalier plus fort on
voit
très malheureusement il a pas l'entrée
là il y aura B6
et le pion G7 est fixé donc là maxime a
réussi à très bien jouer à Maxime et
n'attend plus fort que son adversaire
c'est déjà la première nouvelle
la différence de niveau est très
importante
ok ça c'est tout reprend à 8 c'est sûr
tu reprends à 8 ce qui calcule Maxime là
prend 8 qui va lui aussi ce 3 F7
cavalier d837 qui est français 6 puis on
prend ça déjà c'est une vraie question
est-ce que cette finale peut gagner
c'est peut-être possible on peut
peut-être mettre un pion en Beko à trop
bizarre de pas avoir fait cavaluer aussi
il doit penser pour gagner ça ou pas
ouais ça peut gagner
il va faire cavalier des trois peut-être
pour aller en B4 mettre le rang F4 et
après
décaler vers F5
[Musique]
alors ça peut être un truc hyper marlou
ça peut être juste pour rien en fait
ça c'est hyper marlout de faire un coup
pour rien
parce que du coup l'autre se demande
aussi pourquoi
ah c'était hyper marlou et comme il y a
pas de plan pour les noirs issus
pourquoi pour rien quoi
ça peut être supra marlou ça
parce que normalement le roi vent F4 le
cavalier vent F5
ça c'est la normalité en fait on voit un
que le cavalier vent F5 et que le roi
vend F4 en fait on voit qu'on veut tout
avancer d'une case pour ça qu'un tel
coup que cavalier G2 est intéressant
mais maintenant cavalier deux il y a
peut-être G5
le pion h sera passé donc ce sera encore
un autre problème
cavalier G2 donc ouais c'était vraiment
roi F3 pour rien après c'était peut-être
pour push mais ça ça va pas gagner
normalement
ok donc j'ai 5 jouets on a les coups de
part et d'autre
pourquoi un tel Google plutôt que un
Coutel que parce que Vlad dit pourquoi
un tel coup que
du coup on dit pareil écoute
tu vas pas révolutionner la langue
française frérot attention quand même
sur h6 il y a fougé si ça attention
non mais bon c'est quand même embêtant
je frérot il pense qu'il va
révolutionner le français ouais bon ok
un tel coup que ok on dit un tel coup
que qu'est-ce que tu veux y faire
c'est que le français véritable c'est de
le dire comme ça
avec l'idée sur vous aussi
c'est quoi le plan gars mais il y a pas
de plan de guerre en fait ça gagne pas
en fait faut vous l'implant de gain
pourquoi vous êtes là c'est quoi le plan
de gain il y a pas ça existe pas
toujours les plans de gains
pour gagner quoi juste des plans pour
cliquer comme dirait Marc au pire Jarnac
pourtant quand même Marc
faut pire je l'arnaque quoi c'est ça le
plan de gain
normal
ok mais roi BK
pas de plan de gain juste des plans pour
clic
il veut fout des trois l'enfoiré
H6 intermédiaire est peut-être mal ça
c'est B quoi trop oh bah oui oh bon ça
c'est pas de bol c'est bien bon ça ça
s'appelle un Pione
oh c'est trop à 5 ah c'est trop pourquoi
tu joues quoi
dommage le roi est en cage mais ça gagne
facile
ouais
mais c'est trop
et dans le chat ça nous parle de plan de
gain ok il y a pas de plan de gains
juste laisse le jouer en couple
ça avait très très bien quoi juste
laisse le jouer quoi le conseil de
spasfid d'ailleurs important parce qu'il
quand même champion du monde français
si ton adversaire a fait une erreur à
temps il va en faire une encore plus
grosse je crois que c'est vraiment le
Conseil qui s'appliquer à cette partie
c'est souvent ça en fait quand tu joues
contre un tel le plan bien se résume à
laisser jouer juste en fait joue un coup
quoi
ça met en confiance un tel coup que à 5
mètres en confiance
tu dis ok juste il faut que je trouve
une position il doit jouer ça va suffire
bah déjà la première on devrait en salle
son délire avec vous pourrez 5 c'est fou
que ça se passe aussi bien
ah oui mais c'est la phrase important la
phrase de spaskia si ton anniversaire
vient faire une erreur attends il va en
faire encore une pire
c'est des conseils en vrai c'est des
vrais conseils de joueurs c'est pas
c'est pas des blagues en fait vous
pensez que c'est des blagues mais c'est
pas des blagues c'est juste si tu joues
contre un naze quoi il va faire encore
pire c'est sûr
et là c'était encore le cas
donc oui il faut juste que Maxime il
réussisse à temps des positions en
Contrôle
et il va il va faire des erreurs c'est
sûr
c'est sûr
il y a eu le foufran B5 bizarre là il y
a ce coup-là c'est sûr
conseil djokovicien ouais mais c'est
dans beaucoup de jeux comme ça
c'est
Magnus en fait le meilleur pour pousser
à la faute comme ça
donc il faut que Maxime réussisse à être
en contrôle par contre si ça devient
très tactique et très bordélique ça rien
ne sera dangereux
j'en ai du mal je suis laisser gaffer
exactement
exactement il faut vraiment juste
réussir à avoir des positions
stratégiques
où il peut être en contrôle ou l'autre
fait des erreurs
après attention
mais en tout cas parfait faut qu'il
fasse du Space qui pendant tout le match
c'est une situation Napoléon en fait
n'attends après jamais un ennemi qui est
en train de faire une erreur ok je
savais pas mais oui c'est l'idée de
spasquier aussi et ça s'est senti dans
la finale que Sarine il était à côté et
Maxime il avait poussé à la faute
mais ouais
il fait tout re 8 ok bon ça va mais là
il gère mieux Sarine en fait il a mis
son système de Londres en place et
donc là il va avoir une position OK
plus facile à jouer quoi mais là maxime
est en train de très très bien jouer
cavalier E6 cavalier C7 pour cavalier 6
cavalier 5 pour cavalier 4 c'est très
fort
ça va juste obtenir une position normale
le pouce à l'erreur
[Musique]
c'est le système de Londres c'est chiant
à tous les niveaux parce que avec les
plantes à un genre de ouais je sais pas
c'est pas dur à jouer
de quoi elle est magnifique
il a fait il a il a remis le cavalier en
G5
et il faut assis ça c'est hyper bien
joué il replace le cavalier sur sur 4 il
échange le mauvais fou contre le bon fou
donc c'est parfait là ce qu'il fait
mais même là en fait tu en es pas encore
complètement sorti
ok maintenant la question est-ce que
c'est 4 ou pas C4 en fait
attention à cavalier F4 6 qui est
éprangé 6 vous prend des 6
c'est chiant OK et cavalier 4 pour qu'il
prend 4 qui prend le 4 F3
cavalier des deux
puis on prend ses cinq cavaliers B3 et
repris C5 ok il fait cavalier
[Musique]
système de Londres il a une sorte de
petite emprise pénible à Sarine
et ce fou j'essaie de joue jamais à
cause des puntos là
il va falloir se soulager de se cavalier
des deux peut-être venir les changer
[__] un pion aussi
ramener le rond en 17 il commence par
pion aussi allez à partir vers il veut
pas échanger en E4 OK
il doit pas vouloir changer la structure
ce cavalier en B7 est plus très agile
ah ce système de Londres il est pénible
on va commencer à se faire taper
colonnage le roi est un peu faible
la Sarine joue bien là ça rime
il aurait fallu partir avec cavalier 4
probablement Maxime là qui est obligé de
se contorsionner pour recontrôler la
case 5
et après je pense que le plan de Maxime
c'est tout à 7 tours B7 et B5 et ces
quatre B5 ok en fait
ah mais cavaliers
7 C4 B5 en gros
si il peut
le setup de Sarine est assez dangereux
là c'est relativement bien joué
ok plus de 25 secondes d'avance pour
farine allez ça tient prendre la nul ici
ce serait vraiment bien d'ailleurs la
ligne de l'ordi c'est au rachat tour à 7
cavaliers j'avais pas vu mais en fait
toute la ligne de l'ordi toute l'idée
c'est de faire ce que je vous ai montré
en fait
c'est vraiment relou
pour 7 cavaliers GK
c'est tellement dangereux
ça a l'air de mater
il va la perdre Maxime
embêtant d'avoir été pris comme ça sur
le London
alors cavalier 4 7
il veut remettre le fond à F8 et se
barrer avec le rang en courant
mais il va pas toucher
alors il veut faire un setup ou genre si
l'autre fait cavalier 5 il va faire 8
après
non il veut un set up avec la Touran G8
OK
[Musique]
prendre des quatre intermédiaires pour
B8 fous je te reprends B2
bah c'est céder c'est sûr
oh là
bizarre ça
mais ça a l'air de tenir on leur dit
donne tourgé 7 ans j'essaie de toura8
mais ce sera
probablement pas joué
ok c'est hyper fort ouais ok c'est
magnifique là ce qu'il fait parce qu'en
fait tu as reprend ses sept il y a tout
à 8 et 38 maths
et là-dessus il a prise et fous prend
ses 5 ça va revenir avec toi D8 ouais ok
oui bien
fort très très bien joué
très belle partie de sa réunion rien à
dire
je pense que Maxime a pas démérité sur
la game
la partie a été impressionnante il a
dominé de A à Z
OK
il va falloir
trouver des solutions
comme ça
et donc tu as l'impression qu'il y a
l'air parce que avant nous apprenait
qu'il y avait r alors que en fait
c'est hyper dangereux
ouais c'est chose qu'on jouait pas avant
donc
il y a pas mal de gens qui ont du qui
ont pas forcément la rêve de la
puissance du London
donc juste pour dire si vous posez la
question sur
sur
3 pour double attaque il faut
gagner le pion c'est ça
OK
évidemment
position est compliqué mais j'ai
l'impression que les pièces blanches ont
un truc d'organisation bizarre
surtout la tour
C2 qui est Descartes qui prend des
cadres en 4
temps
on se fait mater quoi
je comprends pas l'idée sur qu'elle
prend des quatre si elle prend des
cartes de me prendre des quatre
point quatre
il y a pas d'idée en fait
ouais attention Maxime il se fait
défoncer en fait
j'ai raté
qui sont forts à la ligne numéro 1 de
l'ordi c'est dam prend B2
quand même
et important quand même
je sais
c'est joli quoi
évidemment il y a pas de prix son
attaque la dame et on attaque le fou
donc à faire pousser 7 encore à la fin
et il faut ranger deux il veut 5 je
suppose si je dis pas n'importe quoi
sur dame
là
probablement la ligne qu'il avait de
base en fait
ok Sarine qui met trop de temps à jouer
c'est bien
il fait confiance en ses qualités
touristiques à la fin
mais mon fou prend c'est 7 là il faut
reprendre le pion quand même
mais ça devrait faire nul
ok faut 5 quand même peut-être et on a
pas le temps de tourner
ouais
on va pas faire mieux ici
OK
dame
il va de façon on a encore du dames
c'est 4 éventuellement
est-ce que ta F5 on a un tour D4 bizarre
c'est trop quand même
on a envie d'envoyer d'envoyer des coups
comme ça mais c'est trop trop
d'affaiblir la première rangée attention
aussi aux pions là qui peut être faible
on n'a pas de F3 il y a le fou envie
[Musique]
on n'a jamais de façon le fouet attaquer
faut ranger 7
il y a tu reprends le 3 ouais peut-être
tour des 4 quand même
il fait H3 le coup le plus sage
ça lui donne le roi H2 évidemment dont
il a besoin depuis tout à l'heure et
peut-être maintenant tour des 4
temps F4 évidemment c'est le truc à
calculer aussi
autour j'ai 4 d'ailleurs faut prendre
trois temps je sais pas c'est compliqué
c'est ultra compliqué par toi les NiAl
qui a pas trop de temps
est-ce qu'on peut avoir un cavalier de
dessin qu'au prochain d'ailleurs
ce qu'il y a du cavalier des cinko ici
tu aurais 8 cavaliers c'est 7 peut-être
un calculer
peut-être même du cavalier B5 qui fait
foudé 4 et liquide
il va y avoir tourgé 6 quand même et
torgée 3 il veut peut-être jouer avec FG
ok il prend une fois
ah bah là il y a tellement de prises
je pense ça juste faire [__] le plus
simple
est-ce qu'il fait froid
ou Tanger
3 à mon avis ouais
dame F2 est trop
ok il veut tout O2 en face il veut pas
de draw donc tout
waouh qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ah
taureau
ok Maxime qui envoie
mais bon il va pas pouvoir garder le
pion de plus malheureusement
mettre la tour c'est Maxime tour à trois
il va faire [__] des quatre à bien
jouer ça farine
mais tour 2
tour F2 il va mettre le rang H2 allez
Maxime allez rois h2g4 allez on avance
là et allez on met la marche avant
oh bien joué dans F4
remettre la structure en place
alors c'est nul mais ça rime en finale
ça a pas été l'assurance touriste
est-ce que Maxime peut faire quelque
chose je le sens hésitant là ça arrive
ses Arbites qui fait
il les Arbi en finale allez un petit peu
à 5 peut-être il est il est très très
Arbi
alors souvent il y a tout F3 là
faut G2 il a tout reprend FC
allez Maxime bon il envoie le pion c'est
il a pas l'air bien Sarine oh oh c'est
pas très technique côté Sarine c'est pas
très technique maxime a trouvé le talon
d'Achille
maxime a trouvé le talon d'Achille et
c'est déjà la pause oh mais c'est trop
bon allez pas de pause là il y en a
marre des poses à 45 minutes Maxime veut
clique ah j'en ai marre des pauses
allez Maxime va chercher un problème sur
régler le problème du London
mais oui maxime est plus fort en finale
c'est évident
e première partie Maxime un meilleur
joueur d'échec
Sarine quand il a ses systèmes et que
c'est tactique il est très dangereux
c'est un match très chaud
mais on a vu sur les deux victoires de
Maxime que quand les positions
devenaient techniques il est plus fort
ça pour moi c'est une évidence
mais ouais ça va être serré parce que
c'est un combat asymétrique chaque
joueur à son avantage
fait pas son lit ouais
on va voir
non ça va être serré
j'ai l'impression que Maxime est un peu
plus fort mais bon après
on sait pas
faire mal je sais pas avant 2h30 c'est
une heure normale pour jouer
mais je sais même pas si il est ils sont
souvent en Europe les joueurs indiens
donc c'est pas sûr qu'il soit en Inde là
c'est même loin d'être sûr
intéressant normal
c'est intéressant ouais
je pense aussi que ça ressemble plus à
une chambre d'hôtel ou un Airbnb Sarine
là
cette pause elle vient un peu casser le
rythme c'est dommage
ça fait hôtel pour moi ça fait soit
hôtel soit Airbnb ouais donc c'est
je pense ouais
on va voir en tout cas
allez on va
espérer que ça ça se passe bien la forme
maximale
serait bien de prendre la tête pour la
première fois avec les Noirs il faudrait
arrêter de perdre
je trouve cette pause à en fait ils ont
rajouté des pauses en fait au début des
speechesses au début début il y avait il
y avait peut-être une pause j'avais le
droit de prendre une pause de deux
minutes par jour tu avais le droit de
faire un Time Out de deux ou trois
minutes pour chaque joueur c'était la
pause toilette quoi
et puis il est arrivé les pauses entre
les segments puis maintenant il y a les
pauses au milieu des segments en fait
ils ont rajouté des pauses des poses des
pauses des pauses et d'un truc qui est
pas beaucoup de pause il y a beaucoup de
pause maintenant quoi
et maintenant c'est full pause quoi
ils en ont vraiment rajouter beaucoup
ils veulent le début ouais mais je sais
pas si pubs parce que je pense pas que
ça leur rapporte vraiment les pubs sur
twitch ça rapporte rien quoi donc je
sais pas après il va le temps de pause
allez ça repart pause est terminé il
reste 43 minutes de 5 + 1 déco à trop
des Cyco cavalier F3 cavalier F6 C3 F5
alors là
ouais c'est ça il va rejoindre Londres
bizarre
dans un gambidam du coup avec cette idée
ouais il a il est venu avec cette petite
idée à la con là si je peux me permettre
et il nous dérange
les pions c'est un genre d'attaque de
majorité
vraiment il y a pas un cadre qui met le
cavalier à 6 jusque là ça c'est logique
des seins qui prend des 5
de nouveau se foutait F4 là en fait
c'est pas là c'est pas un Londres mais
c'est quand même un peu les mêmes on
voit ce qu'il veut mettre en place ça
réuni joue bien ces trucs là
tiens la case 5 qui tient la diagonale
il gêne il gêne il gène ni jeune
il veut se débarrasser de ce fruit une
bonne fois pour toute il a raison alors
est-ce qu'il y a faut prendre assister
reprends à 6 ou français celle d'un
Français 7 qui est des seins qui est des
5 puis on des 5
ok heureusement ce cahier des 5 et prend
des 5 va me prendre des cinq et encore
fou et quatre damage 5 G6 MG4 H5
dam G3 dame prend G3 prix G3
tours F3 F5 la finale elle doit être
nulle
je sais pas pourquoi je me suis emballé
dans une variante aussi longue
ok bon allez il faut supprimer ce truc
là et aller l'attaquer allez tout
reprendre let's go c'est pas moi c'est
turbine
c'est moi qui calculait un peu un peu du
caca mais là tu en prends le 3 c'est
turbine puis on prend dame G3 allez
Maxime
allez let's go
ratez
ça c'est erreur ah elle fait mal
celle-là parce que tu reprends le 3
c'était dans les cordes
c'était dans les cordes allez c'est pas
grave parce qu'en fait on est peut-être
bien
en tout cas pas moins bien il y a que 7
tours à 6 qui est dommage mais en fait
si la dame parte on fait ces cinq et on
navigue avec les deux tourelles
je pense qu'il aurait joué tu prends du
lac les Noirs dans cette partie t'es pas
mal là tu peux pas non plus être mieux
mais bon on a du bol c'est pas c'était
pas seul coup mais c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il a pas trouvé il était pas dans
l'obligation d'aller chercher nul donc
ça va
est-ce que tu veux expliquer
les idées des joueurs voilà on a pas
trop le temps malheureusement ça va un
peu vite
mais on essaye de comprendre les parties
mais tu vois il y a trop d'enchaînements
tactiques
après tu as la jauge si tu veux à gauche
avoir le l'évaluation de la position de
l'ordinateur donc là c'est bien joué il
a mis le pion F5 il veut tourner 5
non quoi 8 il replace la dame
donc on veut tout revu et tout F5
maintenant
là c'est bien ce qui fait Maxime il
reprend l'avantage au temps
c'est genre de position dans lesquels
Maxime joue bien normalement mais on a
vu que farine il était dangereux là
bizarrement c'est un match ou Maxime il
domine pas où il domine d'habitude
c'est marrant enfin c'est marrant enfin
c'est pas très amusant quoi mais juste
habituellement on le voit plutôt faire
mal dans le domaine de la tactique dans
le petit jeu tactique la consigne ce
sera peut-être plus compliqué
et c'est plutôt dans le petit jeu
technique qui pourra le surpasser comme
on l'a vu sur les quatre premières
parties
en tout cas il réussit à jouer plus vite
à poser des vrais problèmes je sens
Maxime un peu plus fort dans ce match
donc là c'est normalement
pour des 5 tours 8 ok c'était la ligne
main pour tout le monde
donc
il veut tout 5 récupérer les pions il
est pas moins bien maintenant
il est peut-être pas mieux mais il est
pas moins bien
ce qui fait ABAB il laisse un peu de
Colonna mais je sais pas s'il peut
vraiment l'utiliser
à 4
très ambitieux comme coup parce qu'il a
fait il veut créer une cible en A3
8 ça met la pression parce qu'il y a le
dernier coup
ouais après il a le même enchaînement
quoi ils ont tous les deux le même
enchaînement ça c'est entre guillemets
un peu de bol et un peu de puissance
tactique mais surtout un match c'est pas
toujours toi qui aura le dernier mot en
tout cas c'est vrai que ça fait mal et
on voit il est encore deux minutes
d'avance
il est venu avec de réalisations Maxime
façon s'il veut battre icarbonate au
prochain tour il faudra jouer comme ça
j'aime beaucoup ce que fait Maxime
jusqu'à maintenant dans ce match
qui tombe sous la minute
allez c'est vraiment vraiment positif là
pour Maxime il va faire tout au sein ici
je comprends pas les dénial c'est Dame
des 4 l'idée
[Musique]
8 3 F7 dame C7 ou 7 en G7 3G7 dame 7 ça
l'idée
qu'à ton F5 et soit ton débutant B7 soit
tour des 7
je suppose à chaque fois je suis pas sûr
étourdes 5 niveau de la meuf 6
je suppose je suis pas sur une nouvelle
fois
et dame F5 Dame des 83 F7 dame c'est 7
pour G7 d'un F2 retour G2
ok il fait dame
roi G2
bref je comprends pas en fait le fond de
l'idée
il va jouer avec tour des cartes en fait
j'ai l'impression que les noirs sont
mieux ça en fait que j'arrive pas à
comprendre
le roi blanc m'a l'air plus faible
bras ce pion à 4
ok il veut peut-être se faire croquer
mais bon les pièces noires arrivent
tellement vite
il va faire dame 5 Maxime
ok oui
d'ailleurs dans certains mondes
j'adore la position des noirs allez la
si Maxime peut gagner et faire le break
avec les Blancs derrière ça peut ça peut
nous mettre très très très bien
c'est la première fois qu'un joueur a
une chance de faire quelque chose avec
les Noirs dans ce match
parce que le temps vaut quelque chose
évidemment
12 secondes 7 contre une 42 ça peut être
le moment pour Maxime de passer la
surmultipliée
tu re cinq dames 6
peut-être
il veut quoi il veut dame D83 H7 dame
c'est 7
du coup Maxime commence par dame roi G7
bien jouer et maintenant sur dame 6
à peut-être dame 8 plus pour tenir H5 il
fait dameuse 3 ça touchait H3 aussi
parce que H4 est un coup ou pas il fait
Damas 2 c'est un coup que j'avais aussi
un peu dans le dans le range
c'est joli sadama 2 il peut y avoir un
jour des tours pro E4 dame B1 il vient
retoucher la colonne G
il y a pas de F quoi trop je suppose
E5 alors il veut te reprendre 5 €
F5 alors
ce que tu rêves 5 dames 2
on sera en mesure de prendre des prends
de 5 donc tout refa cinq le problème
c'est tout RE 2
il prend va me Détroit d'accord
j'ai 6 dame c'est le main
et quoi il veut dame B1
torrent 3 ok
dame C2 roi bouge dame tout renforcer ma
tendance
c'est pas de bol tonger en maths oh
c'est pas de bol pour NiAl ah il a pas
eu de bol là-dessus ouais c'est c'est
dommage mais ça fait Punto pour Maxime
ça c'était ouais maintenant c'est
dommage qu'il ait pas fait la spéciale
quand même d'attendre un petit peu parce
qu'on sait jamais allez let's go
variante d'avance de la carreau let's go
le met au supplice et faire le break
oh que oui mais bon sur roi F1 en fait
il y avait dame D1 Tourer un Dame des
trois et on allait on allait bouffer le
pur H3 et c'était et c'était win
c'est pour ça qu'il a gaffe en fait
Maxime il est facile ce soir il joue
très très fort maxi ouais bon quand il
joue comme ça il est très très dur à
prendre je vous l'annonce tout de suite
ouais non là c'est ok c'est les quatre
meilleurs de du début du tournoi qui
était annoncé mvlik enfin dans l'ordre
des carreaux Carlson mvl et ouais c'est
ça ou mvl comme vous préférez
mais c'est le top 4 après comme je
disais cette année Sow est un peu devant
Maxime mais pas du fait qu'il soit plus
fort mais parce qu'il a le tableau plus
facile mais c'est les quatre meilleurs
modifie roux quand même oui bon firou il
est éliminé Maxime non les autres non
plus hein
avant le tournoi ça tire archi
mais on peut faire Fouache 4 il y a pas
de G5 on a du dames G6 il faut H4 dame 7
cavalier 5 peut-être
faudra calculer G5 allez Maxime qui
prend le temps ça rink a décidé
d'accélérer il a pris un petit coup
derrière la carafe NiAl mais bon c'est
là qu'il faut appuyer pour Maxime c'est
maintenant le moment là faire le break
prendre deux points d'avance essayez de
construire là dessus la gagner au noir
peut-être qu'il peut faire au pire fois
H4 d'un musette et cavalier H5 au pire
au cavalier F5 même
non
G6
fin c'est un peu abusé après
c'est du coup la ligne qu'on avait aussi
pour jouer dans mes fuites cavalier
prank cavalier prend et jouer pour
fouger 3 appris ce prises cavalid 17 qui
a value enfin un jouet pour la case de 5
quoi du coup il va jouer GF ouais c'est
ce que j'allais vous dire
mais fougères 3 quand même fou prend HG
et dès qu'il fait 5 on a du Dam F5 ou du
cavalier H4 ok c'est de nouveau avantage
Maxime là qui est juste en train de
donner une leçon stratégique anale
Sarine
ouais c'est très très bien joué de la
part de Maxime là qui est en train de
survoler le match
il est réellement en train de survoler
le match la Maximy joue
à un niveau très très élevé notre
champion français ce soir
on a du grand maximum on a du très très
grand Maxime jusqu'à maintenant quand il
joue comme ça ouais il y en a que quatre
ou cinq normalement sur la planète qui
peuvent
qui peuvent le battre mais normalement
c'est pas c'est pas ce qu'on en face
maintenant il va falloir côté Maxime
réussir à maintenir ce niveau de jeu on
sait que Maxime c'est parfois là où il a
un peu pêché c'est dans l'intensité sur
sur quatre heures consécutives en tout
cas là après un peu plus d'une heure de
jeu on peut dire qu'il a il est parti
sur de très très grosses bases là il va
faire dame F5
il va jouer sur le clouage il va après
préparer tous deux tours
car elle est H4 c'était l'autre coup qui
était proposé aussi tout à l'heure ouais
là il est il est parti sur des bases
Jumbo vis Metz
je sais qu'il est fan de cyclisme enfin
j'aime pas ce que mais naturel pourtant
quand même
medium bovis Metz
pourtant là c'est c'est très très
difficile pour NiAl Sarine
non naturel mais c'est fort mais c'est
naturel là ça va venir en F5 avec la
dame peut-être
avec le cavalier veut fuite
peut-être il y a la tour qui va naviguer
en E3 l'autre en
2 3 puis on prend puis on prend sur tout
reprend on va pouvoir reprendre du pion
taper six
bon faut juste que Maxime ouais enfin il
est il est exceptionnel c'est le niveau
de jeu de Maxime là c'est
c'est top top top top
[Musique]
qui connaît bien donc les London et tout
donc poser son jeu là dessus et c'est
les embrouilles tactiques
et je pense aussi qui peut avoir un peu
le l'avantage de la jeunesse NiAl et que
il aura probablement moins de baisse de
régime que Maxime donc là c'est fou F4
évidemment tout ça c'était vu un pour
tenir le pion E3 à l'avance Maxime qui
regarde ses options mais normalement
c'est faux F4 tout aurait fait un tour
F3 il fait de la F3 pour cavalier F5
c'est aussi très bien joué
ouais ouais qui va être malin là ça va
être B3 pour le fermer voilà ça s'est
joué instantanément maintenant cavalier
F5 pour le fermer
tout frais fin pour commencer à taper
mais la partie n'est pas encore gagnée
c'est dommage 5 comprend les priorités
de partout
et ce qui va pouvoir faire le décalage
après
maxime est simplement un joueur d'échec
tellement plus fort
et c'est là qu'on voit à quel point
maxime est un joueur complet à on dit
souvent qu'il est moins bon stratège
que des joueurs du calibre de Magnus
voire même
moi je sais pas de quelques joueurs du
Top 50 mondial même que Ding ou quoi
mais on voit que dès qu'on est contre
des des joueurs du deuxième tiers de
tableau
Maxime stratégiquement c'est un monstre
bon les calculs si tout F3 cavalier des
6 qui est prendre des six vous prend des
sistes hors G3 dame B1 Roy F2 dame c'est
de wife 3 ça gagne ou quelque chose
comme ça
c'est pour ça qu'il prend le temps ici
complexe pas simple
Maxime qui veut pas laisser se filer ce
demi-point
il veut revenir avec ta meuf 5 sur
damage 5 il doit avoir une mare loutre
et sur dame 4 il a froid il a poussé sa
dame des 7 c'est trop
sur dame je pense qu'il a poussé sept
un pas sur
non il a poussé cette taureau 8 Dame des
ça gagne pas complètement tout de suite
mais le cavalier va revenir en F5 après
je pense c'est ça l'idée
c'est trop c'est trop poussé cette
reprend F6 ou Dame des 7 ouais
et Dame
des 7 qui rôde
elle est très importante [__] que
c'est vraiment là la balle de break il a
réussi à gagner au noir et quand il
vient mettre pression au blanc
garder la tête de Sarine sous l'eau dans
la cuvette des chiottes c'est tout ce
qu'il essaie de faire Maxime
mais oui cette idée fou c'est ça trop
d'effort ouais
allez en plus on commence à être mieux
autant ici
Sarine qui tank
et maintenant il va falloir
après ça il va falloir que Maxime
continue son travail de sape et qu'il
essaye au moins de tirer nul au noir
mais là ouais si dans le chat vous avez
l'impression que ça arrive ne fait pas
d'erreur c'est juste que les erreurs qui
fait ce sont des erreurs stratégiques et
il est mis au supplice dans la
compréhension du jeu par Maxime qui le
survole
pour une raison inexplicable
il y avait plus fou F4 à cause de dames
1 maths
et là x heureusement qu'il a raté il a
raté fou prend le 5 puis on prend le 5
et tu reprends le 5 oh c'était dur et il
y avait pas de reprendre le 5 à cause de
dame en maths
heureusement
donc il a fait cavalier 7 et tout F2
heureusement qu'il rate ça NiAl
ça aurait pu être un coup dur
ça ça aurait pu être un coup très dur
ça faisait que du
sur bon jeu blanc
voilà
dame 6 et ça va rentrer
cavalier 6 car il prend G6 prise ouais
ou dame prend H6 d'abord ça gagne c'est
Punto les 4 de Let's Go ça là elle fait
mal c'est le premier break dans un match
très serré jusqu'à maintenant
et NiAl qui veut retourner dans cette
position
ok Maxime qui veut
il va mettre le fond F5 je pense et
dames
5 prend B3 rock B4 A6 en fait ça me
rappelle un truc que joue sauf que
normalement au tempo ça peut aller ou ne
pas aller
et là on a quand même gagné un temps
ah il a ses petites lignes et ses
petites idées
ouais normalement c'est la même avec un
temps de moins comme on dit dans le chat
mais bon des fois tu as des petites
idées comme ça avec des problèmes
pratiques qui peuvent arriver et que tu
peux avoir du mal à régler en blitz
bon
c'est position à ça on a compris ça il
joue bien
en fait il joue bien les positions avec
des plans clairs et précis
donc
les tours C8 sûrement ou tour quelque
part
je sais pas
je suis avec
je mettrai juste par principe un cheval
en 4
mais c'est vraiment par principe quoi
pour essayer de me faire du 5 peut-être
un jour
je sais pas j'aurais pas une giga
conviction dessus mais je sais pas c'est
que ce serait ma manière de continuer le
jeu quoi
fuite
en fait peut-être qu'il a peur de se
retrouver en situation ou s'il prend
l'autre prend du pion
ok il a provoqué le C5
alors maintenant le plan classique c'est
B4 cavalier des deux cavaliers B3 qui va
dire à 5
faire attention pas le prendre ok il va
pas se prendre ce qui veut caille des
deux fois F5 cavalier B3 il a le temps
de 5
donc ça passe
il va être juste au tempo
donc il va faire fouet 5
et 3 il va faire 5
normalement
ah bien joué j'ai 4
oh il est mieux supplice là Maximilien
il a raté G4
et maintenant faut aussi se cavalier B3
il a plu le 5
ah ça fait mal ça parce que si t'as pas
E5 tu es très mal
il va falloir redoubler d'ingéniosité là
parce que car il est B5 qui a validé 7
c'est une vraie menace donc cavalier
cavalier à 5 qui veut partir prendre G4
c'est ça
et là il va faire tourner 8 tours des 7
il fait fout des sept
cavaliers à 5 qui veut cavalier E68
il est pas bien la maxime
ça c'est typiquement le truc que tu ne
dois pas te prendre en fait
ok l'idéal ce serait de pouvoir ouais en
fait il y a pas assez de casse pour les
pièces pour avoir une tour à fuite une
tour en 8 le fou en C8 le cavalier en 17
et faire 5
si on avait le placement de pièces
parfait
ah il a mis la tour en à 7 c'est triste
c'est triste
à la partie d'une tristesse
et c'est un peu là qu'on voit la force
de farine c'est à dire que quand il joue
ses positions et ses systèmes
il est connaît bien et il est assez
précis il a plus le problème stratégique
en fait
il a plus le problème d'être dominé
stratégiquement il peut faire parler son
calcul
bah du coup Maxime qui donne une cale
c'est ça qui est fort en fait
bon c'est qualité de moi
très très bien joué là
il débraye pas mais il menace de des
briques
très très bonne partie de miel
Maxime il a un problème sur des 4
et avec les Blancs il a pas de zone
clair ici cibles
d'accord on comprend bien le l'enjeu du
match là maintenant
Maxime garde le break d'avance ouais
mais
mais sarin est là et il rôde quoi
je sais pas ce qu'il faut qu'il joue il
peut régler le problème de différentes
manières il peut tenter un B5 en one
shot
qui est censé pas être terrible
cependant
ok bon on a cette structure
d'un genre d'attaque pas neuf à l'envers
Maxime F4 donc qui joue le genre de
cavalier peelsbury
mais en fait il peut pas vraiment
ça pour le moment en tout cas
partie importante une nouvelle fois faut
pas qu'il lâche les trains avec les
Blancs pas de laisser revenir
le seul côté négatif c'est que Maxime
il a pas de cible chez Sarine pour le
moment avec les Blancs il change
l'ouverture
et il obtient des bonnes positions
enfin il réussit à bien dominer on va
dire quand il a l'initiative en revanche
ça réduit à une cible claire dans le jeu
de Maxime
suivant comment le match se déroule
ça peut être bien ou pas bien quoi
disons problème en fait il aura plus de
il aura plus de problèmes
et Maxime avec les Blancs chaque partie
est nouvelle donc
vous m'avez compris quoi
vous avez compris un peu l'enjeu à
positif ou négatif qui peut y avoir à ça
donc c'est intéressant
il a plus de problème
bah ouais parce qu'en quelque sorte
comme il n'y a qu'une seule arme pour
Sarine au blanc
si si ferme le système de Londres et qui
réussit à égaliser il va
systématiquement égaliser en fait dans
le match
dans les cadences plus courtes ça il
aura moins de temps de calcul ce sera de
mieux pour Maxime bah il y a aussi
l'argument inverse c'est comme il
connaît très bien son schéma système de
Londres là
lorsque le matcha avance il peut avoir
encore plus de facilité enchaîner les
coups
bon Damas 5 il tape le pion C3 on n'a
pas trop parlé de la partie mais en gros
il y a cette structure il y a le fou F5
qui est toujours pénible en fait vous
voyez il essaye quand même de retrouver
des éléments du système de Londres avec
les Noirs ça me bute en fait
OTP London c'est un OTP London
on a l'impression là que ça Rin
a repris le match à l'endroit j'ai
quatre est un coup c'est un coup
c'est d'ailleurs jouer
et des trois pions
il veut jouer à l'activité une nouvelle
fois
entre quel champion
à Cali
agressif quand même mais c'est assez
frauduleux comme perso
je sais pas ce que ce serait mais bon
ça va être le fond je sais pas un bonne
question en tout cas
ouais je pense que c'est un ADC déjà
London très clairement
je pense pas que ça peut être top je
pense c'est forcément à DC
peut-être supporter
en tout cas c'est sûr que c'est pénible
jouer contre
mais ouais c'est pas si compliqué cela
donne mais ça fait mal vous l'avez vu
aussi d'ailleurs dans le speedrun
pédagogique
rien qu'avec les tout petits plans
simple que je vous montre en réussit à
mettre à mal les joueurs à 1800-1900
sans rien faire de très difficile et là
on voit même qu'un joueur comme comme
Maxime peut avoir du mal avec les Noirs
contre un spécialiste en [__] de ce
London il est il est pas facile à gérer
en tout cas la maxime à son pion de plus
après les cavaliers vont être forts et
surtout vont taper sur les pions C3 et
E3
la jauge préfère les Noirs mais
c'est quand même un pion il a peur de
fou même stade l'activité
Maxime qui rend et il veut mettre le
fond en F2
ok mais ça commence à être bizarre en
fait parce qu'il a donné son bon fou
mais il a dû penser qu'il pouvait pas
faire autrement et il se retrouve avec
un pion en F2 en fait il a deux pions
plus Maxime
et il est complètement tenu ah il va
peut-être se faire des briquets là
là il va peut-être se faire des briquets
la position est très difficile à tenir
et ça réunit une nouvelle fois quand il
peut avoir l'initiative il est vraiment
très fort c'est pas un match up habituel
pour Maxime match vraiment très
intéressant
pour une fois on a notre Maxime qui est
plus fort sur son point entre guillemets
plus faible
allez faut tenir mettre mettre les tours
sur les colonnes H3 il veut il veut
blinder le pion
est-ce que ça pourrait pas être un hiver
ne le donne
non en fait je sais ce que c'est London
c'est Yumi évidemment
c'est sous un doute you me
F4
c'est clairement Yumi en fait
sans aucun doute
bienvenue c'est sûr en fait une fois que
tu as compris c'est Yumi elle a tortana
F4 c'est fort parce que dame prend F5
ah alors dis mon te reprends F4F Dame
des trois tours 8 vu par Maxime
évidemment
vu par Maxime
oh là là quelle défense ton G1 pour pour
prise et reprise et échanger
Maxime qui est en train de la défendre
là qu'est-ce que c'était bien joué j'ai
acheté ton géant évidemment vu un par
notre requin aux lunettes et là il va
faire EF
ça reste pas clair puisqu'elle cavalier
avec ses chiant mais c'est ce qui donne
les meilleurs chances de tenir
alors là alors du montage 6 super fort
ou oui H6 maxima
parce que sur pion prend on pourra
ramener la tour en G8 et taper sur G7 et
sur roi prend il y a trois fuite maths
donc H6 ça force G6 mais après on peut
jouer pour foi H4 fois F6 c'est et toi
si Maxime h si si va la tenir sinon ça
reste dur
H6 ça ressemble au maths de Carlson
caryakin et il a allez bien jouer Maxime
ça c'est un joli coup ça fait mal ça
ça c'est un coup qui fait mal
facile une fois que tu as très difficile
d'y penser mais une fois que tu l'as
c'est facile à jouer
ce H6 et G6 ça va être fois H4 tempo
allez faut H4 il a fait tout recettes
manquez pas le mail de l'ordi mais qui a
un joli coup
sur dame F5 je sais pas comment il veut
traiter le truc
qui a validé des 6 c'est pas mal joué
cavalier d'ici aussi de la part de NiAl
il prend à 7 Maxime pour il va bouffer
les pions
là il y a du FCO qui est fort mais dur à
voir
ton G2
waouh attendez cette qu'est-ce que c'est
Ford à F4 qui a fougé trois enfilade et
c'est ton point F7 maintenant
et c'est foish4 et c'est fou j'ai 5
étouchettes et c'est ciao
popo mesdames et messieurs oh il doit
pas être bien NiAl oh il doit pas être
bien
oh le Maxime oh le tour des 7 qu'il a
trouvé oh il a été bon ok est-ce qu'il a
été bon Maxime oh là là dans le petit
jeu tactique il lui a rappelé qui était
le papa
voilà elle fait très très mal à la tête
celle-là elle fait extrêmement mal à la
tête celle-là
oh là là le tour des sets de de
revenus des Enfers et il a enchaîné quoi
après
il a trouvé la magouille avec oh là là
là avec avec Fouad c'est impressionnant
attention là Maxime il est pas trop mal
sorti du London cette fois-ci
là il peut faire extrêmement mal il peut
les corps chez là
dernière partie en 5 + 5 il peut
l'écorcher
là il est il a il a il a peut-être réglé
le problème
la plus 3 ça peut faire un énorme bien
ouais s'il gagne celle-là il se met
tellement la tête à l'endroit
ouais ça rime qui est pas très bien
ça il y a fatigué les gars je crois
qu'il en voyage en Europe donc il doit
être 20h48 frère arrête de trop tu
arrêtes arrêtes de chercher des excuses
à Sarine il est juste surclassé par plus
fort que lui il a
dès que ça gagne côté Maxime on cherche
les excuses pour les adversaires dans le
chat et oui later son de sortie
c'est 53 ou 5 de ces 5 3 c'est 5 3 5 3
on a le mauvais score là le bon score de
toute façon ce sera toujours celui en
bas
ça ça commence à semer là dans le dans
le chat allez c'est pas fait encore pour
Maxime le match est long
et tu reprends des cinq il y a quoi ah
il y a quatre
ça a rien qui est en train de revenir au
score
ça peut revenir au score là avec avec
cette petite tactique placé
vous devez être content là dans le chat
certains vous allez pouvoir nous dire
que Maxime est fini tôt
en tout cas c'est la dernière partie en
5 + 5 après il y aura la posa
elle est importante pas la perdre
celle-là avant la pose
des 6 c'est peut-être à 6
complexe
une nouvelle fois
les cavalu aussi c'est la pas du faire à
cause de fous des images je suppose
bon là c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
c'est bien
prendre un demi point tourné à plus de
ce serait parfait
c'est F5 tempo
c'est bien il joue vite Maxime
donc ça tient le cavalier ça ouvre la
diagonale du fou il y a le pion des 5
qui peut être en l'air un jour attention
pour le moment il y a toujours fous ces
quatre mais si on fait à 6 B5 tout d'un
coup le pion va être comestible
donc là il veut A6 qui va lire à 3
clairement
et sur quel idée il doit vouloir payer 4
dames prank et des trois dans quelque
chose comme ça je suppose
même sur dame français 5 j'y crois pas
trop en fait
c'est pour te reprendre des seins
évidemment
tellement plus logique de venir
récupérer des cinq
et donc tous ces quatre il veut à 6
cavaliers à 3 B5 AB3
OK
c'est hyper bien joué
allez gagner cette partie là ce serait
exceptionnel déjà tenir la dro
maintenir cette petite longueur d'avance
car il y a trois donc là il va y avoir à
et B5 comme dit auparavant sur abeille
Adam prend à 3
pour moi ça rine en petite difficulté là
étant prends des cinq
suivis de tour des 8 et rentrer
6 bien joué aussi il va replacer le fond
en G8 ça va défendre le roi et attaquer
là il a une superposition Maxime deux
minutes d'avance
la gamme d'avant elle fait elle fait
vraiment tourner le match de notre côté
bon il y avait une petite domination de
Maxime mais évidemment c'est normal
qu'un cas une flippe favorable du coup
mettre la tête sous l'oignon ne pas
laisser revenir
allez prise cavalides
OK
prise prise ok ça paraît bien
mais le pion c'est 5 maintenant peut
être fragile alors il menace pas tout de
suite ce qu'il y a dame prend des deux
il fait dame B4 c'est bien joué il veut
taper sur
sur B3
mais peut-être que ouais ce que j'allais
dire peut-être qu'un truc comme cavalier
3 fou prend B3 sa liquide en tout cas il
y a pas de risque de défaite là pour
Maxime donc tourner à plus de ce serait
déjà très positif surtout qu'on récupère
de nouveau les blancs
ça me permet vraiment de tourner
en ayant le break d'avance maintenant
avec l'avantage autant le pion de plus
c'est la pression
on est en droit de vouloir mieux je
comprends pas l'évaluation de l'ordi
d'ailleurs un 0,40 là c'est vraiment peu
parce que on n'a pas de son plus égalité
matérielle je raconte n'importe mais on
a l'impression d'avoir un pion de plus
on a la perte de fou la position est
ouverte il y a tout qui se passe bien
regardez le roi maintenant qui est en
super sécurité derrière les deux fous
qui tapent
mais bon le cavalier en des 4
et un joli socle donc il fait F4 Maxime
il va mettre la dame en B8 je suppose
ou un F8 ouais c'est la même chose on
protège le pion
c'est échanger mais ça va donner des
fois H6 peut-être pour déloger la tour
Maxime la veut faire il veut faire la
différence là c'est sûr qu'il faut faire
la différence Maxime sur cette game
il y a des Fouday 4 cavaliers G4 fou B3
qui peuvent roder ouais il décale la
tour
qu'est-ce que ça fait mal le tour est
fuite ça c'est des cookies qui font mal
parce que
c'est comme un Rubik's Cube quoi il est
en train de changer le sens
de son attaque
mais bon pour le moment il réussit pas
encore à terminer
peut-être jouer un coup comme dame G5
pour tampon Dame des 4 propose l'échange
des dames
c'est accepter
par Sarine et bon maintenant le roi va
monter le pouvoir revenir en E5 ou en F6
d'ailleurs pour pas se faire toucher par
la tour
la tour revient en D8 est-ce que la tour
va passer vers D2 maintenant il veut
peut-être éviter tout ces deux quand
même il peut commencer peut-être par un
fou B3 alors
ma fumé 3 ça peut être malin ça peut
être chiant avec peu de temps
ah fous ces quatre fous des quatre fous
j'ai 8 3G 8
et qui a validé 1 il y a C2 il doit pas
être bien NiAl
et ça c'est ton problème de frérot il
doit pas être bien
ah il doit pas être bien là
il doit pas être bien allez il a l'air
de dessus à la cam
il faut finir le boulot maintenant
proprement pour Maxime
la position est gagnante mais elle est
pas encore gagnée
il fait à 5 il veut mettre le pion H4
pour complètement le fermer
maintenant fouet 5 échecs
alors dit redonne égale c'est incroyable
parce qu'il y a roi géant
ah c'est trop
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
Maxime qui nous a pas gratifié
d'une concentration jusqu'à la fin du
segment
à quel dommage
alors est-ce que faut trois tours ces
trois fois F4 pour B2
il tout fou j'ai trois peut être marlou
c'est ce qui va faire évidemment
et là il y a air c'est ça le problème
ok
ouais 7
océan il y a fou F2 échec qui arrive
en fait je sais pas pourquoi mais il y a
que qui gagne pas
oh bah ça c'est tout rêve 2 et tour des
deux non
ça c'est ça s'appelle pièce
non ça c'est une pièce signale oh il
doit pas être bien NiAl il doit pas être
bien et ça fait trois points
il avait peu de temps et Maxime a réussi
à capitaliser
ouais il doit pas être il a pas l'air
d'être bien
il a pas l'air d'être bien
bon trois chats bon je sais pas pourquoi
c'est gagné pas mais on s'en fout en
vrai pourquoi on rachète gagnait pas
c'est Maxime qui a gagné
mais ouais là il lui a fait il lui a
fait très très mal dans cette game hein
surtout il a réglé son ouverture il a
fait comment alors pour régler
l'ouverture il est parti sur G3 il a
laissé revenir avec cavaliers B5 comme
tout à l'heure
mais il a pas peur du temps à ramener le
cavalier en C7 il a tout juste tué pour
E5 en profitant de ce truc là
ok on a compris comment Maxime avait
réglé ce petit problème
je veux savoir est-ce que ni aller bien
ah il doit pas être bien
ni elle doit pas être bien là
très très clairement
si vous me demandez ce que NiAl est bien
ou pas
moi ce que je pense c'est que il doit
pas être bien
ouais là Maxime il joue il joue vraiment
fort plus 3 il a les blancs
il arrive pas à résister à la puissance
de Maxime
pense pas qu'il puisse
renverser la vapeur après attention il
sent un bon joueur de Bleach Sonia
combien de temps la pause sont assez
longues les pauses salade et c'est
peut-être la plus longue elle est
peut-être de 10 minutes là
très bon joueur de belette aussi ouais
il faut il faut maintenir l'écart là
pour Maxime faut pas se relâcher
faut pas faire une relation il faut il
faut garder cette avance
il doit pas être bien là
donc ouais elle a prochain
mais oui bien sûr
c'est encore la pause il y a pas mal de
pause
en tout cas très très bon début pour
Maxime
maintenant capitaliser
bon on attend on attend la fin de la
pause
qu'est-ce qu'il fait la différence ben
flamme Maxim il joue mieux quand il
comprend mieux le jeu quoi
c'est peut-être ça la différence
il fait vraiment un très très beau début
maintenant le changement de cadence
c'est toujours important de bien
l'entamer ça peut changer la dynamique
ça peut être non je pense sur ce qu'on a
vu Maxime va pas se faire dominant
belette mais ce serait bien de l'entamer
avec 4,5 points d'avance
j'écris à Maxime
en secret avec Maxime à la mi-temps
bon on attend le retour
voilà on a un patient de voir le retour
du match
on espère en tout cas
que Maxime mettre le même en train
les joueurs sont de retour ça devrait
reprendre
donc là on va avoir une fin deux fois
une demi-heure en fait
ça va être coupé en deux en quelque
sorte
allez ça repart
un petit peu trop G6 des Quattro
fougez 7 donc c'est un changement de
stratégie côté Sarine
3 + 1 ça va être plus dynamique le la
cadence est réellement nettement plus
rapide moins le temps de prendre le
temps justement dans l'ouverture
Maxime qui cale vite le fond en B3
qui va jouer tranquille avec H3 donc il
bloque un peu le la sortie du four
bien joué à B6 x 6 de la part de farine
provoque ces quatre
c'est 5 et des 5 ouais
structure de type
suivant ce qui se passe
j'ai pas parti alors si elle est partie
alors là j'ai parti
allez mettre tout de suite
ça Rhino supplice en danger
qui 5 x 3 positions est très complexe
il va logiquement partir pour petit rock
mais ce que j'aime bien chez Maxime
c'est qui continue à jouer très vite il
domine autant Sarine vraiment très
nettement
je pense qu'il va faire foi à 4
pour échanger le fou contre le cavalier
ok il a pas fait
attention à la position quand même il
peut il peut se faire fixer
il peut se faire bloquer sur quasiment
avoir les pions fixés sur casse blanche
il va falloir tenter tout retro
ah par contre ça peut faire mal ah ouais
mais c'est trop la NiAl c'est trop là ce
qui fait NiAl en fait il a pas de
Counter à tout trois
chance max pour Maxime
ah ça c'est pas de bol
ça c'est vraiment pas de bol
ouais bah c'est pas de bol
c'est pas de bol ce que toi F7 c'est un
parable alors peut-être qu'il a un peu
de chance dans sa malchance
et là maintenant plus Maxime il va avoir
du X4 il y a peut-être fou français 4
qui sauvent encore fou prend des sept
fou prend F1
il fait même pas fousser le cadre bon ok
c'est fou prends des 7 là c'est terminé
et c'est tout fuite ah il est
complètement taré en fait et torgée 8
c'est maths c'est ciao et roi H6 c'est
dam F4 dans 5 à Houda ME3 peut-être même
plus facile et j'ai 5 tours F5 ou Dame
des deux même encore plus facile
peut-être
bon ça fait plus 4 ça commence à
s'alourdir le score
après ils ont mis victoire Sarine
c'est Maxime qui a gagné non
ils me font peur attendez je vais je
tiens avec là parce qu'il me mette un
coup de pression de chaise comme
je crois qu'il vient de gagner oui non
non c'est bon c'est bon
ils m'ont fait peur
et là on a vu un Maxime qui a trouvé la
solution quand même plus ou moins assez
soucis
à Pagnant on a eu peur ouais
c'était quoi coupesque comme comme
changement de
score côté de chez cam
heureusement qu'on était sauvé par le à
pignon
heureusement que tu as pignon nous a
sauvé en tout cas Maxime qui fait les
cars
tu vas prendre ces cas tu poses enfin
prendre 5 d'abord
et prendre ces quatre ici
et prendre H3 ok c'est encore une autre
manière de jouer
en tout cas le début de match est très
très réussi
mais il faut tout le temps en continu
c'est un format il faut pas de coup de
mou Maxime je me répète mais qui nous a
parfois
habitué à des petites des petites
sorties
de mages des petites déconcentration et
là aujourd'hui
il faudra les éviter au maximum
ce qui peut être dangereux en belette
NiAl et c'est un joueur globalement
dangereux après comme je disais un
maximum il a Xbox 4 catégories au dessus
normalement
tu avais les dessins quand même la
position est complexe là
il y a deux majorité à 4 4 contre 2 donc
c'est un jeu vraiment compliqué les
Blancs ont un peu plus de cases mais les
pions noirs sont un peu plus avancés
sur qui prend B5 il doit y avoir un
problème ah mais la cavalier prend tout
bêtement
Maxime qui se dirige vers des trois
maintenant
c'est intéressant de la part de nuit
Alain ce qu'il fait
il laisse les pieds avancer mais il a
des cases derrière le roi noir peut
peut-être se retrouver faible un jour
même si pour le moment il est pas à
table
c'est jamais simple
la petite à petit la position de Maxime
est en train de prendre forme oui il lui
fait très très très très mal
ah ouais il le il le met au supplice
il est mis au supplice
il est extrêmement marlou Maxim il est
il est très très fort ce soir ce soir
ah s'il y a une salade c'est plus simple
je vous ai dit ainsi Maxime règle le
problème du London
bah il a plus de problème
et il semble avoir réglé ce problème
donc signal ne tape plus
lorsqu'il a les pièces blanches ou la
cavalier prend F2 cavalier prend F5 car
il prend F5 croit pour F2 dame E3 roi F1
cavaliers 3 attention NiAl
il cale quand même un fou des cinq
intermédiaires
ok c'est très bien joué parce qu'il veut
roi et fuit dame C3
ok c'est très bien joué ça c'est très
bien joué
ouais ça c'est très très bien la maxime
est en grand danger dans cette partie
il y en a qui pourrait un peu revenir
attention
OK
ok mais quand Maxime il joue comme ça il
est trop fort
des 5 et [__]
ok mais il est juste beaucoup trop fort
étendez 6 maintenant pour dame F5 ton F6
dans le ok c'est trop non mais c'est
trop et maintenant qui prend des six
protège et cavaliers 4 non mais c'est
trop là ce qui fait Maxime
ok là il a raté dame prend le 3 échec
quand même en un mais globalement ouais
ok c'est fou pour moi ouais pour moi il
doit y avoir fouilla après ce match côté
côté français
ouais non ok là il faut fouiller
pour moi c'est une obligation là on peut
pas laisser Maxime continue à jouer
comme ça
la fouille me semble obligatoire pour
pouvoir continuer ce match
je sais pas confiance à Maxime trop fort
pour moi ça vibre chez Maxime
je peux pas croire à un tel niveau de
jeu il a toutes les tactiques il a tous
les coups
signal qui se retrouve mal au temps
supposait être un excellent genre de
belette mais c'est lui qui suit en fait
il va faire dame G7 là c'est
3 fois
ouais ça fait mal aussi
ranger 8 pour éviter les échecs et là il
a peut-être du dame F2 pour prendre des
un
c'était le coup de leur dire que je vous
ai dit dur à voir
il faut pas qu'il faut pas qu'il se
laisse tomber
non
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait Maxime aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe
ah mais c'est trop ça il faut s'acheter
une nouvelle souris
c'est trop
ah c'est trop il revient à trois points
à Maxime la qui laisse qui laisse passer
une grosse chance et ça relance le match
là en quelque sorte
c'est dommage dominait tellement Maxime
jusqu'à maintenant
et là il tombe bêtement
peut-être les vibrations du plug qui
l'ont
trompé
déstabilisé
plus simplifiant ouais je pensais que
c'était l'idée depuis le début en fait
d'un Français 3
mais ouais on a ouais peut-être une
histoire de Plug qui vibre un peu fort
côté Maxime et qui coûte cher
allez il faut il faut continuer
et se relancer
parc la Nouvelle-Zélande fait très très
mal
bon une position correcte
mais pas l'avantage
c'est jusqu'à maintenant il joue des
parties plutôt tranquille
sur l'ouverture
à la maxime qui retrouve petit à petit
son meilleur niveau et quand il joue
bien
il est quand même très très
impressionnant
le numéro de français
pour nous offrir un match de gala contre
contre Caro un peu la bête noire de
Maxime quand même mikaro
ah il menace fou B6 quand même parce que
sur tourbe 5 allez peut-être glisser la
tour en D1 maintenant on va prendre la
colonne
ah non mais ça met du baume au coeur un
de revoir Maxime à ce niveau
il fait quelle idée pour qu'il y a trois
c'est un peu la même idée
puis cavalier c'est 5 bien joué roi G7
de Niall
viens c'est 5 évidemment
la NiAl fait une bonne partie ouais le
maximum là qui vient de tomber elle fait
mal à la menace d'un grand BK
heureusement on a encore fou des 6 pour
tenir
mais c'est dur
petit passage à David de Maxime après
après le flag
NiAl qui joue avec beaucoup de
certitudes là les derniers coups
est-ce qu'il a raison parce que la tour
a pas accès à G6 donc est-ce que son
attaque est si forte que ça on va
bientôt le voir
OK
menace rien pour le moment
maintenant il faut rentrer dans la
position adverse alors est-ce qu'il veut
enlever cavalier de échec avant de le
faire en faisant roi H2 ou pas
il le fait il peut avoir du G3 aussi
parfois mais attention ça ouvre la
deuxième
en tout cas là il joue vraiment bien
Maxime il a juste eu un micro passage à
vide il est tombé on sait pas trop ce
qui s'est passé
si vous êtes un BK ouais sauf si tu fais
ton dessin
ça permet de retenir la case F8
donc la table 3 tours qui va arriver
peut-être pour des 6
peut-être pour des deux peut-être pour
des 5 qui arrive aussi
tourner cette menace d'un massette quand
même à bien jouer tour F6 jolie
qui va remettre le ranger deux à qui
joue pas dans sa qui est sur laquelle je
voulais répondre tout à l'heure alors
j'ai 8
c'est peut-être Baki dans le plug
OK
oh là il y a dame prend
B5 peut-être il y a pas fou et fuite
c'est encore protégé par le Punto
Dame des cinq
c'est bien joué dame dessin mais H4
aussi il veut revenir avec le cavalier
en F4
pour la partie est compliquée
dans des tours
et surtout à huit fois trois je pense il
va prendre et mettre le va peut-être
tomber 7 tomber 7 tours à deux fois
trois on tourne ici ça change rien ça
charge juste le roi il faut à trois
direct
oh attention tomber si si votre tour il
veut venir mater
est-ce qu'on peut jouer au roi G4 alors
c'est la question que je me posais aussi
tu auras suite ça peut être un coup ton
dessin bien joué attention on peut pas
sacrifier la qualité sinon il y aurait
tout reprend à trois pions et B2 B1
il faut être hyper vigilant sur cette
idée là
oh ça c'est bien joué de la part de
Sarine pour cavalier F4 tourage 4 au feu
c'est très bien joué aussi pour tout
reprendre j'ai 5
c'est fort
alors absolument rien n'est fait
mais maintenant il contrôle la case F4
il peut faire tomber quoi et c'est ok
c'est plug en fait
voilà en fait c'est full first line pour
Maxime c'est impressionnant
attention quand même au 5
ouais 4 encore très bien joué pour F4
maintenant
oh le niveau de jeu de Maxime et que en
c'est juste écœurant il va faire tomber
4 c'est écœurant
c'est complètement écœurant
ouais c'est terriblement écœurant
pour pour NiAl
le cavalier qui va se faire chasser va
en B8 avec la tour et mater en H8 oh
c'est écœurant
c'est écœurant ce qu'il est en train de
faire Maxime
il a tous les coups il est insupportable
et dire qu'il a perdu une partie en
tombant bêtement mais sinon c'est une
leçon que le joueur français en train de
donner il pourrait en réalité il aurait
transformé celle d'avant il y a déjà 9-3
le match est déjà plié
mais il est cœur maximum bye quand il
joue comme ça il est moi je vais pas
faire de match de bits contre Maxime là
dans les joueurs à venir
c'est trop fort ce qu'il fait c'est trop
dur
donc on pourrait déjà gagner
un Maxime dans cette forme là il peut
battre Carlson si je joue comme ça il
peut battre ma gus
il est extrêmement impressionnant
ah si joue comme ça il me dit zéro
aucune chance voilà c'est trop marlou il
y a trop de pression sur chaque coup il
a donné un pion il fait cavalier B4 il
veut taper C2
quand il joue comme ça c'est trop dur
quand tu es en face c'est infernal
contre Caro pense que c'est le seul
adversaire
qui est favori contre Maxime quand il
joue comme ça
je pense c'est le seul joueur au monde à
pouvoir se dire là
je suis favori contre Maxime pour moi il
y a personne d'autre
et on parle sur Internet
là le niveau de jeu de
de Maxime il se rapproche de plus en
plus de son niveau quand il a été
champion du monde
il va faire cavalier le 4 prise 4 faut
prendre
ah il va le cartonner il va récupérer à
dehors ça va être insupportable là
en fait il lui envoie tout reprend ses
trois dans la tronche
ah ouais il fait il fait tellement mal
la maxime oh il est horrible à jouer là
il va quand même mettre le cavalier à
deux il va les faire [__]
non
il en fait peut-être un peu trop là
il en fait peut-être un poil trop
le 4 c'est la casse de 4 c'est la case
du cavalier
il est pas forcément besoin de se
sacrifice de calme
du coup il envoie comme ça
en force
en fait
il a il arrive pas il arrive plus à se
mettre en place Sarine en fait la maxime
il lâche un peu les chevaux tactiquement
il veut juste se faire passer sous la
table
en quelque sorte
ah il veut la battre ouais
là il veut juste la battre
sous la table c'est comme comme quand tu
prends 10 € que tu es Fanny quoi
ils veulent exterminer en fait
il veut faire cavalier 4 quand même ça
le truc
il veut cavalier F3 cavaliers
à 3 et 4 échec
surtout prends en fait il voulait 4
OK
tu vas aller au 4 2 tours c'est un deux
il veut torcer ah c'est pas mal joué
parce qu'en fait le cavalier il colle la
case F7
c'est l'idée de Sarine
d'où le tour c'est 7
est-ce que c'est malin de faire cavalier
4 3 C2 cavaliers C3 et tour à 7 je sais
pas
il fait tour à 7 direct
ah c'est une gaffe
il a gaffé Maxime
et il abandonne
Sarine qui recolle à trois points
maximum à trophée une nouvelle fois
ah
ça c'est la nouvelle variante là des
des indiens à la contre l'Espagnol
quel dommage
ah c'est dommage ça c'est des petits
demi points qui qui nous échappent
il reste à trois points farine
avec leurs ordis
pourtant le nom quand même
je connais jamais les noms des
ouvertures de façon moins c'est simple
ah j'aime pas trop ça Maxime qui laisse
passer deux occases là au noir
j'aime pas laisser passer des occas ça
remet les adversaires en jeu
quand même KF4 qui prend le 5
fois il le replante encore une fois
ouais bah en fait je sais pas pourquoi
je suis inquiet
quand il joue comme ça en fait pourquoi
s'inquiéter
il va te faire dame prend à 8
prendre bonus offensif pour la
Nouvelle-Zélande
avec l'équipe de France la question
c'est ce qu'on va réussir à battre un
ami
ensuite tellement l'équipe de France
c'est terrible
il maintient la double attaque Maxime
c'est bien joué
super pour eux qui sauveront l'honneur
en mettant un essai
OK
il avait pas le temps de roquer parce
qu'il y avait dame prend à 8 et là il y
a pas d'âme prend
j'ai 7 sur X à la mafia tu veux tout
fuite
et après sur
quand même pas mal de réussite
réussite max là pour Niall
c'est pour ça que j'aime pas trop Maxime
qui rate ses chances parce que
normal d'avoir un peu de réussite à un
moment donné
OK
ma position est compliquée
juste ça aurait pu être gagnant pour
Maxime directement
Adam G3 il faut F4
il veut tourner deux et grands rock
Maxime
en fait
pour pour taper le long de la colonne
des
allez garder ses quarts de 4 points là
le remettre en place
il restera combien de temps là on va on
va être arrivé à la pause 27 30
on sera la mi-temps du 3 plus 1
le tour des deux grands rock
attendez deux fois H4 ce serait sympa le
coup de cale flow ça nous permettrait de
gagner une dame en un coup histoire des
deux tours des 6 on fait quand même
grand rock et là c'est fou c'est ça hein
ça ça s'appelle une cale
tu rajoutes
c'est pas
prends
à me trois
oh si c'est bien joué quel joli coup
il veut
il veut fixer le roi et bloquer cette
colonne mais il a un problème de roi
Maxime quand même
ah il y a pas torgée de à cause de fois
H4 donc croit F1 pour tour G2
très bien joué
il y a le Sarine qui a plus de 20
secondes
Maxime 10 08
que de passe d'armes dans ce match
tourner un tour pendant prise D1 dame 1
ça me prend B3
allez tordez deux pour tour D8 et
cavaliers C6 maths
ça met bien de menacer mat quand même
vous savez très très bien et même dame
aussi si à tour des 8 recettes cavaliers
c'est si ce matin quand même
un entourez nimp
moi aussi je suis un petit peu fatigué
c'est tellement tactique comme partie
ils m'ont Tanger 3 c'est tellement bien
joué oh ça aussi c'est bien joué dans ma
chambre
attention de pas se faire enfiler mais
il y a pas et la dame D8 x 8 seul coup
d'âme des 6 3 G8 et tour G2 puzzle
pour mais quelle level
mais quel les vols de Maxime oh il a
l'air il a il a le seum Sarine
ah le patron qui rappelle les bases
quand même
oh il a spot maintenant 5 en une
demi-seconde ouais bon il rappelle il
rappelle deux trois bases
ah ça rini il a le seum là oh regardez
le seum oh le sol en une image
c'est terrible pour lui
regardez l'image du seum regardez c'est
incroyable
il a un seum incroyable
et ouais je cherche toujours des Belges
pour mon match et que moi sur discord
j'ai pas eu le temps de répondre
malheureusement aujourd'hui mais trop de
trop de travail
il est en voyageant en Europe et à
Bruxelles en fait c'est très clair
ah il est pas bien là
il est pas bien en tout cas un gros
match de Maxime il reste à plus 4 il va
falloir construire là dessus
garder cette avance et terminer en
belette après vu le niveau que Maxime a
dans le petit jeu tactique aujourd'hui
je suis pas très inquiet de la de la
face bolet hein très franchement
ça se prononce bel et toi ouais je sais
je sais je sais
je sais je sais on dit on dit le bolet
je comprends l'animal depuis tantôt oh
ça peut être belle ça
le tantôt me fait penser à du belge
ou lyonnais ouais mais c'est à peu près
la même chose
ça peut être normal aussi le tantôt
tantôt ça va être québécois aussi ouais
on attend c'est la pause
c'est un match en fait donc à chaque
fois que tu gagnes des parties tu mets
des points quoi en gros
là c'est beau quoi
incroyable dans le chat c'est magnifique
en fait
je vois que vous êtes ça l'organique ça
exceptionnel
prochaine
dis-toi que je suis
live à 14h donc dis-toi que ça fait 8h50
que je regardais
dans 7h50 que je regardais speech là
ça me paraît aussi en terminale
moi aussi j'ai l'impression que c'est ça
n'arrête pas en fait
tu es vraiment long et pas intéressant
ouais celui-là est plus me les parties
sont plus marrant ouais
allez ça repart pour le système de
Londres une énième fois
mais là c'est marrant parce qu'on a
Maxime aussi
on a un peu biaisé
ça change un peu les ordres de coups
vous voulez baissez 5 Maxime je pense
donc il l'a fait
[Musique]
c'est clairement le coup de Maxime si
c'est fort c'est
peut-être prendre prendre qui a valucate
prendre et s'ouvrir le fou
prendre à 5 peut-être
F3 cavalier 7
à 3 il y a B 4 c'est sûr
ouais farine j'ai l'impression que c'est
vraiment un OTP London
en tout cas par Maxime qui tape le fou
cette logique du coup on va prendre mais
ça a supprimé le fou on reste avec le
mauvais fou mais peut-être c'est pas si
grave
une dame c'est 7
je pense qu'il va jouer avec H5 un de
l'autre côté mareski
H5 maintenant
c'était sûr
OK
on n'a jamais réussi à trop prendre le
large en fait on a eu des balles de plus
5 des positions de plus 5 qui ont été
ratées
c'est peut-être le moment
et maintenant tu auras suite peut-être
ah il va peut-être faire tout reprendre
et tout rachuite
cavalier jouable
8 sûrement
et rentrer en H2 mais en fait il va
reprendre de la dame à la fin
donc
tous les trucs de type ranger gratuit
Regarder dame bouge tout rage 2
mais en fait il en fait genre un truc
comme ça
ça pourrait passer quoi
malheureusement il y a
à Paris le 23 bah si il est libre c'est
sûr qu'il sera là
il veut tout âge 4 maintenant
allez il faut prendre G4 et cavaliers 4
ça va passer un de ces quatre
ouais c'était sûr que c'est ce qu'il
voulait faire Maxime
allez cavalier prend il voulait
ah ça c'est fort
parce que là tu reprends la suite il est
obligé de faire roi prend mais Adam
prend H4 donc ouais
à Maxime qui réussit pas à prendre le
large Sarine qui reste proche on a raté
l'occasion plutôt
pas simple ce match pas simple ce match
il est vraiment pas simple ce match
bien défendu un de la part de farine
bravo à lui
c'est extrêmement bien joué
maximum
à mon avis
il faut trois dames des deux ça paraît
simple
dit c'est bien ça relance le match ouais
mais sauf que nous on veut pas le
relancer ce match
on veut pas le relancer du tout
on va absolument pas qui se relance on
aimerait bien le conclure une bonne fois
pour toutes mais ouais il tient bien
dans l'ouverture une nouvelle fois
n'écoute pas le temps le juste de resign
parce qu'il y pense pas c'est pas son
caractère Maxime il joue aux échecs
normalement
j'utilise pas des règles bizarres pour
gagner pour et après ça c'est chacun
voit midi à sa porte mais
c'est des règles qui vont à l'encontre
de l'esprit même des échecs en fait
savoir au moins une question de faire
play mais enfin on avait déjà parlé
cette histoire de jouer sur du temps
déjà pas des scores
c'est un peu le même truc qu'ils avaient
essayé au tennis mais le tennis la vite
la essayer et la vie oubliée
bien joué F4 là
et Caro étaient infect pourquoi tu écris
je comprends pas le dans ta phrase par
si faible utilité du mot hier en fait
en fait la phrase elle est un peu
bizarre
pas jouer ce qui a validé des quatre
parce qu'en fait il me reste cavalier C2
et puis on prendra pas tout reprendre et
ces deux il veut jouer dame prend B6
Maxime
c'est marrant mais cette position elle
est hyper dur à jouer pour les noirs
Maxime il hésite à faire F5 ou apprendre
à un
il y a pas de colonne pour les tours
faut absolument faire auprès F4 je pense
quoi que pas sûr je dis peut-être de la
merde
je pense quoi de la controverse du chaos
quel controverse je suis pas là je suis
pas au courant pour le coup
en fait il est complètement enfermé à
avec le cas sans son match pour moi il y
a pas de controverse le casque est
autorisé car on a le droit de le mettre
il le met pour moi il y a pas de souci
pour moi il y a pas de controverse il a
le droit il le fait
ça rend fou les adversaires aussi cette
attitude donc c'est tout bénef
[Musique]
ok
Maxime si vous pouvez grande en fait les
qualités on voit un cale je suis pas
je pense qu'il va un moment donné je
veux un B5 Maxime là il y Adam c'est 5
pour le moment donc c'est pour ça il
fait ces 5 plutôt
un peu bordélique ce truc quand même
il veut quoi dame prend des 6 d'un
en fait il doit regretter de pas avoir
commencé par un roi H1 quand même
parce que c'est le problème c'est pour
ça que Dame des 4 marche
ça c'est maintenant il doit pas être
bien
ah il est pas bien farine
s'il doit pas être bien quand même de se
prendre un matin ou non
et on reprend plus 4
il doit avoir l'écran T2 ou fin
c'est normal à ce niveau ouais mais la
position est tellement dure à jouer pour
ça
c'était juste dur en fait
ça rien qui s'accroche il reste
quatre points il a réussi à maintenir
les carres
j'espère juste que ma passion une purge
contre le tour suivant on espère tous
sur formation
mais en fait c'est une ouverture qui lui
convient très bien
et il est très bon avec
c'est pas les blancs en fait son
problème dans ce match avec les Blancs
il a plutôt de mon résultat son problème
c'est les Noirs farine donc c'est
logique qui change pas d'ouverture avec
les Blancs
tant qu'il est à 4 points ouais il est
il a porté de fusil tu gagnes deux
parties et ça y est quoi tu es là
sans problème c'est son problème en fait
les blancs il a pas de il a pas de souci
on voit qu'il a des bons résultats
et avec les Noirs c'est plus
problématique
bien évidemment
c'est lui qui va jouer avec la qualité
de moi mais oui il a beaucoup
d'activités là
mais réussi à rester à quatre points
et à revenir même souvent à trois points
donc il suffirait qu'il en vole une avec
les noirs et il reviendra deux points et
regagne avec les Blancs ce qu'il a
l'habitude de faire il peut être un
point fait il peut très très vite se
retrouver à -1 en fait
il continue à gagner avec les Blancs il
en style Une avec les noirs
si fort en belette il m'inquiète pas
trop franchement quand Maxime joue comme
ça je pense pas qu'il puisse être moins
fort en belette mais bon le Bullet c'est
des vagues en fait s'il joue en match en
partie je suis pas inquiet mais là il va
y en avoir 10 tu prends une mauvaise
vague tu perds 7 3 c'est pas c'est pas
honteux quoi
donc tout sera encore possible
par contre si Maxime pas ça 6 points là
ce sera bon
le 4 c'est bien joué
est-ce que Maxime est dans une bonne
dynamique oui
sûrement faire d'un me prend ces quatre
30 parties en puissance fait 15 parties
dans ça fait entre 8 et 10
pour le moment
il y a un clouage
en 4 points ça te donne un bon 95% de
chance de gagner mais c'est pas 100%
si tourner s'il gagne celle-là et qu'on
tourne à plus 6 on serait proche de 100%
. voilà il a contre cloué
si on gagne ça là et qu'on gagne la
prochaine
au blanc la on aurait on aurait vraiment
le match le match déjà gagné quasiment
il reste sûrement deux parties d'après
celle-là en 3 plus simple ou une dure à
dire
ok ce qui va faire tourner un oui
très fort aussi la dame B4 c'est hyper
fort
ah oui ça ça peut être le couplage
là ça peut passer
ça me prend c'est français 4
tours à 3 allez
gagner ce pion
gagner ce pion pour gagner ce match
allez s'il y a une option B3 il va faire
dame si slash
je vois bien tenter un dame 6 pour aller
foot le beau ah non il y a d'un point F4
pardon il peut même pas faire ça
ah ouais donc il est vraiment pas bien
il fait à prendre il va y avoir ses
prend probablement cavaliers des deux C3
cavaliers C4 encore B3 c'est Punto et ça
va filer Adam il va prendre à quatre
aussi au passage Maxime il faut pas lui
demander deux fois avant de prendre un
punto gratuit
et là il faut trouver une solution pour
avancer il va faire tour à 5
pour chasser le cavalier c'était sûr
c'est le coup logique et
se replacer en B5 avec la tour
à fout des deux tellement bien joué au
passage et B3
et tour à deux
et B2 et ça gagne Maxime qui prend 5
points
celle-là elle fait un bien énorme
mais ça repart sur sur la pétrole qu'on
avait vu au tout début
alors c'est pas encore terminé
mais là on commence à avoir un vrai
matelas c'est qu'on a même le droit même
le luxe
de perdre avec les Blancs
et garder un avantage net
mais la cigogne avec les Blancs plus 6
ce sera fin de match mesdames et
messieurs
les dernières m'ont détesté Maxime ouais
Maxime réussit à manger le chrono
l'amener à zéro et faire nul et attaquer
les belettes à plus 5 c'est aussi très
confort même perdre et confortable en
fait
mais tourner à plus 5 ce serait
exceptionnel
on a plus 5 ce serait exceptionnel on
nous aurait dit ça avant le début de du
match on aurait signé tout de suite
avoir plus 6 ça permettrait de d'aborder
les choses
même Sarine n'y croirait plus quoi
c'est ça le truc plus 6 même
l'adversaire est abattu
ce
ouais c'est bien à 4XX
le temps qui reste c'est en haut à
gauche normalement c'est la dernière
partie en 3 plus 1
je revois le chrono théoriquement ils
peuvent mais je pense que pendant les
parties vont pas le regarder
les trois est faible ouais mais si les
noirs peuvent venir l'attaquer je sais
pas trop
ça peut être faible
mais les blancs
il va
replacer le cavalier en B5 Maxime pour
le couvrir le pion essayer de mettre
l'autre en C4 et le fond en C3 attention
à pousser deux
regarde tout le temps bah normalement il
vaut mieux pas regarder
le gagnant jouera contre richardoun a
camera
mais là clairement c'est la
dernière partie du truc
52 ouais la partie elle devrait
il termine la partie ouais le chrono
tombe à zéro c'est juste qu'il y aura
pas de nouvelles parties
intéressantes ce que foutezka tu veux
plus en prendre B3
faut prendre B6 B2 je pense
j'avais pas vu
intéressant ça
c'est la ligne de l'ordinaire
trouvent en calculant mais jolie ligne
stratégie idéale pour batterie carreaux
ouais c'est difficile à dire
je crois qu'il y a une ligne un peu
bizarre
qui peut passer avec un genre tour D8
vous prend à 5 je raconte peut-être
n'importe
même probablement
en fait on a qu'à éponge ici sur échec
c'est probablement plutôt cavalier
fiston
ah je sais pas
attendu tout prendre merci j'ai du mal à
voir là
je commence à faire des fautes
de temps en temps
même si le B2 c'était allé mais des fois
sur des coussins je rate
ça fait peur mais
on sait trois qui est prend ses trois
tours C8
qui fait aussi peur ah faut 3 bien joué
il est tombé
ah mais c'est trop il s'en appelle même
pas rendu compte encore
il a bug Sarine
ah il a perdu Sakho
oh défaite par déco oh bah ça fait
plaisir oh bon ça c'est oui bon ça c'est
pris il doit pas être bien quand même
ah il doit pas être bien oh bah ça fait
12 à 6
ouais bon c'est fin du match en fait
c'est pas de bol
bon Maxime qui se barre c'est quand même
pas de chance
c'était on avait dit à -4 c'était cool -
5 c'était super plus enfin 6 du coup
plus 6 pour Maxime
surtout en gagnant à la co avant les
bullets en fait c'est ouais
bon une nouvelle fois on s'était pas
trompé sur le vainqueur du match ah
c'était ouais faut pas écouter lia de
chaise comme qui donne du 55 ans
il disait quoi le smarts il est
complètement cataclysmique ce truc
complètement
j'ai le Smart chasse
ok ça donne celui de Carlson qu'on n'est
pas c'est Qatar
ouais une autre paire de manche
ce sera une autre paire de manche
mais Sarine c'était sûr que c'était
ouais ce que je vous ai dit un survetic
et c'était aussi dead là c'est pareil
oh mais cool beau match de Maxime
il Caro qui disait ça une favori il est
délito
il est complètement déduit Caro
c'est trop
mais c'est je vous en ai déjà parlé du
problème mvl
c'est que les gens pensent toujours
quand même vérifier les finito et après
ils ont le seum quand ils voient que
c'est pas le cas et ça c'est vraiment
c'est le problème mvl en fait
il y a énormément de gens qui
qui sont touchés par le problème mvl
il y a énormément de gens qui sont
touchés par ce problème
qui fait mal
après Maxime il va être énorme favori
favori contre Maxime quand même ça va
être du 80 20
va falloir que Maxime joue aussi bien
que ce soit sur toutes les parties sans
passage à vide comme il l'a eu et
peut-être il aura une chance
ce qu'il y a pas gagné il gagne tous les
tous les bullets ah ouais il a plus de
connexion en fait ça
la connexion de l'hôtel qui a craqué à
côté de
ouais bon c'est le match est terminé
c'est pas intéressant quoi le match est
plus intéressant
l'écart est tellement important
déjà de base mais là
ça va être encore pire
le prochain anniversaire c'est Caro
exactement demi-finale
ce serai Caro
[Musique]
ce soir c'est une démonstration
à peu près pareil
après
pas du tout donné ce ratio là mais oui
sur sur Internet ouais
mais le maillot a aussi qui carie
qui carie très fort
ça sera vraiment à cause du Bullet ouais
enfin tu peux l'être sur Internet Bullet
sur les Ch'tis réels c'est pas pareil
c'est vraiment pas pareil
ça se joue tellement sur des détails
tous ces trucs là
le maillot oublié de Stream qui carie
toujours hein
là j'ai plus de la ville avec la souris
qu'avec le poignet
allez ça repart on va dire qu'il manque
deux points à Maxime pour gagner ce
match on va essayer de les mettre tout
de suite et ça rien qui joue plus
vraiment à London là mais qui joue à un
genre de B3 mais quand même avec des
idées
de semis London alors attention il est
très dangereux en belette
mettre rapidement le Punto ce serait
parfait
au Maxime qui recommence à super bien
jouer en fait ouais bon ce soir il est
trop fort
il a mis la tête de Sarine sous l'eau
trop solide Maxime
il va y avoir dame B2 ouais bon il
il écrase à rinky écoeurée
farine qui est juste écœuré
et Maxime qui a une domination totale de
l'échiquier
va faire cavalier 5 je pense quand même
être tour ces trois puits cavaliers 5
non il l'a pas
et 3 ouais c'est fort ça
madame prend des quatre ouais
ça va être une purgea ça à partir de
maintenant trop d'écart
3 c'est vrai ça en fait déjà une
et le score qui fait que enfler
maintenant c'est plus sept
ouais ça a rien qui tire qui sait plus
quoi faire
bon belette ça se joue un peu ce truc là
mais bon c'est trop
c'est un carnage quoi
il a le droit d'abandonner non on n'a
pas le droit d'abandonner tu as 10
minutes de la fin
mais il y a quand même très très peu de
retournements de situation dans ces
dans cette dans cette compétition
une fois que ça part mal tu es quand
même en grand danger
le chrono est cassé alors si il est
cassé c'est pas moi mais ouais il a
l'air cassé effectivement
sur Instagram il y a pas eu retournement
[Musique]
ce qui va la tenir Maxime je crois
je crois
à 4 et en fait ça ferme
terrible pour
pour NiAl
terrible
ça échange
Maxime c'est ce qui va il prend même pas
nul en fait il essaie de le battre c'est
trop
c'est trop
il va y avoir tout 8 et à huit dames
ah il le fait comme ça en plus ça c'est
dégueulasse que c'est Maxime
c'est dégueulasse il le fait en plus de
la manière la plus sale possible
ça enfle pour pour
terminer déjà mathématiquement
ça met un peu le seum
le match a plus d'intérêt
c'est ici la Nouvelle-Zélande ouais je
crois que c'est un peu le même
c'est un peu le même le même scénario
après je dois dire
quand même et c'est tant mieux mais que
Maxime a un très beau tableau
après c'est mérité il y a les trucs de
tête de série les machins mais
Lucas en 8e c'était peut-être le joueur
le plus le plus faible du truc
un des plus faibles en tout cas
et derrière Sarine en car ok il est pas
si simple
mais ok c'est pas Hikaru c'est pas c'est
pas Wesley c'est pas firu il y avait
quand même
quelques joueurs nettement plus fort
et Maxime qui joue pas le temps
mais après normalement
quoi
en fait
d'après les infos que j'ai il est
vraiment assez faible en blitz
étonnamment d'ailleurs
des sources qui le donnent comme un des
plus faible 27 50 de l'histoire en blitz
alors Sarine c'était plus fort
évidemment
de l'histoire de l'histoire moderne quoi
c'est pas un grand bizarre quoi
elles vont partir plus d'intérêt
maintenant
malheureusement c'est joli hein ce que
fait Maxime mais bon c'est
quand c'est fini c'est fini j'ai envie
de dire
quand c'est fini c'est fini on va
essayer de Master Class de Maxime après
ça joue pour les lobes je sais pas
pourquoi ça joue on arrive pas trop à
comprendre c'est comme le match de tout
à l'heure un moment donné on sait plus
trop pourquoi ça joue
alors pour moi ça commence à être un peu
long je vous cache pas
à 9h sur l'ordi au bout d'un moment
qui est un peu dangereux je suis un peu
Maxime s'envoler ouais mais ça se
ça se sentait
non pas que les joueurs aient le droit
de finir
les matchs avant
donc ils sont obligés de jouer jusqu'au
bout
c'est obligatoire
mais ça a aucun intérêt
c'est contre nature même en quelque
sorte c'est exactement ce que j'ai ça
fait un peu penser au tennis quand ils
ont essayé de faire la réforme pour
arrêter de jouer sur les 7 et jouer sur
le temps
pas le match ouais mais un match de foot
ça dure 90 minutes ça en dure pas
ça dure pas 240 minutes en fait
et puis le foot
déjà c'est plus dans le sens du jeu de
jouer comme ça
mais en plus de ça c'est quand même rare
genre là les speechers c'est quand même
quatre matchs sur 5 qui sont très
déséquilibrés
ou tu pourras arrêter
un moment donné tu dis bon là on peut
arrêter
mais c'est pas par on peut pas comparer
une heure et demie de match à 4h quoi
il va finir ah ouais il va finir à
20h23h c'est ça 4 heures
3h moi il y a une heure de pause enfin
les pauses ça compte quand même
mais j'ai rien à un moment donné où ça
devient clair mais c'est comme j'ai en
fait c'est un peu comme le tennis c'est
contre nature
les jeux à point comme ça c'est fait
pour avoir des sept
ou des ou des enfin ou ça peut être un
set gagnant ça peut être de cette
gagnante 3,7 gagnant mais la nature du
jeu elle veut que ce soit des 7
ça va gagner pour Maxime
ouais ça pique ouais
enfin je sais pas parce que c'est des
parties qui existaient pas
il a fait cavalier
je sais pas je souffre avec les joueurs
en fait
je fais combien
à peine
c'est quand les demi on sait pas
aucune idée on sait enfin personne ne
sait en fait
quand tout le monde va en finir là
là je crois que tout le monde veut en
finir
ce qu'un joueur peut se lever troll
ouais non je pense pas
ils ont des contrats des machins ils
peuvent pas
[Musique]
non tu es obligé de rester c'est juste
ça fait aucun sens
comme pour le match précédent c'est plus
aucun sens
le truc c'est que les joueurs à 10
minutes de la fin je sais pas ils ont
tellement de sommes d'avoir perdu qu'ils
oublient d'abandonner les matchs
c'est ça qui est beau
le plaisir des parties je crois que
enfin ça c'est un délire le plaisir des
partis c'est pas trop le cas enfin c'est
ton métier ça te saoule de jouer mais
c'est juste
il joue par frustration
c'est exactement ça
bon
normalement non
on a déjà eu un peu eu cette position
laisse le temps couler
il laisse le temps couler
on va essayer de nouvelles ouvertures
bref je sais pas enfin
je sais pas quoi dire j'ai mal aux yeux
en fait en vrai en vrai de vrai j'avais
mal aux yeux j'ai plus envie de regarder
l'écran en fait à cause de ça
j'arrive pas à me motiver là pour la fin
du match très franchement je comprends
pas ce qu'on regarde en fait
pour moi quand c'est fini c'est fini je
sais pas comment dire
pour moi le délire à sa joue encore le
plaisir des échecs le machin je sais pas
c'est pas
c'est pas des trucs qui existent pour
moi
pour moi un match il est là pour être
gagné ou perdu tu vas gagner tu l'as
gagné tu l'as perdu tu l'as perdu en
fait je sais pas
je sais pas ce dans ma matrice de penser
j'ai pas ce délire quand un match et que
tu l'as perdu de
là c'est mathématiquement perdu en fait
tu peux faire quoi que tu fasses tu as
perdu
il est pas obligé légalement de
continuer à jouer comme au tennis ah
mais au tennis en fait ça arrive jamais
qu'un match soit perdu
en fait au moment où il est perdu le
match s'arrête là le match est déjà
perdu et il joue encore c'est comme si
tu avais déjà gagné 3 7 et puis qu'on
joue le 4e et le 5e 7 pour pourquoi en
fait on sait pas trop
mais
là c'est littéralement fini en fait il y
a pas de
en fait si
ce qui a 8 points d'écart il y a au
maximum 4 ou 5 parties
tu mets une partie extraordinaire
extraordinaire de quoi en fait
pour moi en fait c'est une partie n'a
plus dangereux elle peut pas être
extraordinaire je sais pas comment dire
c'est c'est fini en fait c'est un match
il est il est fini il y a plus rien
d'extraordinaire en fait
ils vont pas faire du Mozart en belette
quoi
ça existe pas en fait
chaque partie compte pour le fit les
parties qu'on ne pour rien en fait
j'arrive même plus à lire
et ça se voit là il clique juste pour
cliquer
mais bon on s'en fout en fait
ouais je sais pas certains vous avez du
mal à comprendre le délire de toujours
un match pour le gagner une fois qu'il
est gagné il est gagné
c'est ouais ça me bute en fait vous avez
du mal à le comprendre
c'est du concept de match quoi
même si Maxime
mourrait là ce qu'on lui souhaite pas il
aurait quand même gagné le match
j'aurais littéralement mourir il aurait
quand même gagné le match quoi enfin
c'est
quand même violent comme concept
on lui souhaite pas mais après
ça lui enlèverait pas le match quoi
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec ta
vision mais pas là c'est pas une vision
là c'est pas un avis ce que je donne
c'est en fait quand un match est fini il
est fini pour avoir enfin c'est pas une
question de vision
c'est juste le but du match depuis le
début qui dure 4h c'est de le gagner une
fois qu'il est gagné mais il est gagné
quoi c'est pas une vision
après avoir gagné ça ferait aucun sens
en fait
mais c'était Max a très bien joué
c'est un avis du point de vue du gagnant
il faut comprendre qu'il y en a qui
peuvent avoir la mentalité elle est
jusqu'au bout de ne pas abandonner de
vouloir profiter du moment pour jouer
avec un RSA quand même non mais ça fait
3h30 qui joue contre lui frère il vient
de se faire défoncer tu crois qu'il est
content là Sarine il se dit ah ouais
tiens j'ai du bol je joue contre mvl
c'est des sportifs de haut niveau c'est
pas des joueurs du dimanche quoi
ils sont pas là pour
je sais pas comment expliquer quoi il se
dit pas tiens c'est cool
même imaginer ça il va tenter de te
reprendre aussi
pourquoi
je pense que dans leur contrat ils ont
pas le droit de
de Quick même si ça absurde je pense
qu'ils sont obligés de cliquer jusqu'au
bout mais c'est absurde
et ça c'est un résultat attendu une
surprise moi je m'y attendais fortement
pouvez pas me prononcer mais avant ce
qui avait quelques facteurs dont j'étais
pas sûr mais
mais je m'y attendais fortement
Maxime il est nettement plus fort que ça
Rin et en plus là il a bien joué donc
c'est normal qu'il explose
bon allez c'est l'avant dernier il en
reste plus qu'une derrière
ça sera plus dans ah bah ouais là ça va
faire
ça faire exactement 9h que je suis sur
l'ordinateur ça va que très très vite
j'ai même pas eu le temps de
de dîner encore donc non ça va aller
manger très très vite et ça va aller
dormir fort
bonne soirée par avance ouais on verra
un jour on tiendra au courant pour voir
quand Maxime joue contre Carlson ce sera
un beau match
ouais non là Julien on est tous obligé
de regarder jusqu'au bout
on est tous ce qui est blanc avec ce
match mais oui ça fait pas ça ça fait
aucun sens là
ce qu'on regarde ça fait aucun sens
c'est pas un cas ouais c'est contenant
un cadre plus enfin là c'est
Carlson sera contre sobre on écoutait
plus que je dis trop fatigué là
c'était un beau match de Maxime là c'est
un peu le c'est un peu la demi-heure de
trop quoi
c'est un peu la demi-heure de trop pour
tout le monde
et puis en plus là par ampli pour se
faire plaisir et et faire là par exemple
ah non c'est gagnant merde
genre là Maxime il pourrait faire durer
quand même et pense à nous
non
parce que
vous pouvez faire du ré 40 secondes
pour finir le truc
ah il y a des fois il pense pas
collectif Maxime
il pense pas collectivement
le match serait déjà terminé
en tout cas un gros match vraiment très
très gros match de Maxime là il va
peut-être abandonner NiAl mais d'abord
voilà là ça tu peux abandonner frère
voilà bravo nickel belle abandon
meilleur des moments bravo NiAl
très très belle abandon de NiAl dans le
très très bon time ça j'ai eu peur qu'il
abandonne avec deux secondes de jeu ça
aurait été terrible
bon victoire de Maxime du coup 19 et
demi à 11h30 un match très propre les
joueurs sont déjà déconnectés donc on va
se laisser et ben on se tient au courant
et ce sera la semaine prochaine donc la
grande finale sous les joues la somme
battle le 23 Paris
hierl n'hésitez pas à me contacter sur
discord ou twitch